you
okay senators
representative degette just showed how
the insurrectionists
believed and understood themselves to be
following
president trump's marching orders she
explained in chilling detail
how they were acting in perfect
alignment with his political
instructions
and his explicit strategy to retain
power
they did what he told them to do this
pro-trump insurrection did not spring
into life
out of thin air we saw how trump spent
months cultivating america's most
dangerous
extremist groups we saw how he riled
them up
with corrosive lies and violent rhetoric
so much so that they were ready and
eager
for their most dangerous mission in
validating the will of the people
to keep donald trump in office but
we must remember that this was not the
first time donald trump had inflamed and
incited a mob
trump knew that his incitement would
result in violence not only because of
the thousands of violent messages
that were posted all over the forums and
the widespread
news of preparations for violence among
extremist groups and his
communications on twitter with the
insurrectionists themselves
he knew it also because he'd seen
many of the exact same
groups he was mobilizing participate
in extremist violence before
moreover he'd seen clearly how his own
incitement to violence
and praise after the violence took place
galvanized encouraged and electrified
these extremist followers these tactics
were
road tested january 6 was
a culmination of the president's actions
not an aberration from them the
insurrection
was the most violent and dangerous
episode
so far in donald trump's
continuing pattern and practice
of inciting violence but i emphasize so
far
earlier congresswoman plaskett showed
several episodes
of trump's incitement that took place
during
the presidential election but his
encouragement of violence against
other public officials who he thought
had crossed him
long predates the 2020 campaign
the incitement of violence is always
dangerous but it's uniquely intolerable
when done by the president of the united
states of america
but that became the norm
on president trump's watch white
supremacists and extremist groups
have spread like wildfire across the
land
his own department of homeland security
called homegrown
terrorism the number one threat facing
americans today
but no matter how many people inside and
outside government
begged him to condemn extreme elements
promoting violence and indeed civil war
in america in race war in america he
just wouldn't do it
and that's because he wanted to incite
and provoke their violence
for his own political gain and for his
own
strategic objectives ever since he
became president trump
revealed what he thought of political
violence
for his side he praised it and he
encouraged it
right now i'm going to play for you just
a few clips from over the years
when the president's words successfully
incited his supporters
into assaulting his opponents
see the first group i was nice oh take
your time
the second group i was pretty nice the
third group
i'll be a little more violent and the
fourth group i'll say get the hell out
of here
all right yeah get him the hell out of
here will you please
get him out of here throw them out
i get a little notice in case you see
the security guys we have wonderful
security guys they said
mr trump there may be somebody with
tomatoes in the audience
so if you see somebody getting ready to
throw a tomato
knock the crap out of him would you
seriously
okay just knock the hell i promise you
i will pay for the legal fees i promise
i
uh we've seen these clips and many many
more like them before
but think about the brutal power
and effectiveness of his words with his
followers you heard him
told his supporters to be a little more
violent and they responded to his
command
by literally dragging a protester across
the floor
at one of his campaign rallies he cried
get him the hell out of here throw him
out
his supporters punched and kicked
another protesters he was escorted from
the hall
he told he told supporters to knock the
hell out of people who opposed him
and promised to pay the legal fees of
the assailants
time after time he encouraged violence
his supporters listened
and they got the message but it wasn't
just trump's encouragement
of violence that conditioned his
supporters to participate
in this insurrection on january 6. it
was also his explicit
sanctioning of the violence after
it took place let's watch some of those
incidents
beginning with trump praising supporters
who had assaulted
a black protester
uh but we've had a couple that were
really violent and the particular one
when i said
like that bang them that was a uh
a very very very you know he was a guy
who was swinging very loud
and then started swinging at the
audience and you know what the audience
swung
back and i thought it was very very
appropriate he was swinging he was
hitting people
and the audience hit back and that's
what we need a little bit more
we'll talk to you about that later yeah
but there's not going to be time i'm
just curious
tired of you guys the last time you came
here you did the same thing
get the hell out of here get the hell
out of here
the last guy did the same thing you were
the guardian yes and you just broke my
glasses you last guy did the same damn
thing you just
body slammed me and broke my glasses but
greg is smart
and by the way never wrestle him do you
understand that never
any guy that can do a body slam he's my
kid
we did not initiate force against
anybody we're not non-violent we'll
[ __ ] kill these people if we haven't
i do think there's blame yes i think
there's blame on both sides you look at
you look at both sides i think there's
blame on both sides and you also had
people
that were very fine people on both sides
so just in case you didn't catch all of
that the president praised a republican
candidate
who assaulted a journalist as my kind of
guy
he said there were quote very fine
people on both sides when
the neo-nazis the klansmen and proud
boys
invaded the city the great city of
charlottesville
and killed heather heyer and he said
that an attack on a black protester at
one of his rallies
was very very appropriate does that
sound familiar listen to how president
trump responded
when asked about his own conduct
on january the 6th
so if you read my speech and many people
have done it it's been analyzed and
people thought that what i said was
totally appropriate
so there the pattern is staring us in
the face
very very appropriate he said after a
man was assaulted at one of his rallies
totally appropriate was how he
characterized his incitement
on january 6th meaning that of course
given the chance he would gladly do it
again because why would he not engage
in totally appropriate conduct an
examination of his past statements makes
it clear
that when donald trump tells the crowd
as he did on january 6
fight like hell or you won't have a
country anymore
he meant for them to fight like hell
on january 6 that became clear to all of
america
now let's consider the event senators
that took place last year in michigan
where president trump demonstrated his
willingness and his ability
to incite violence against government
officials who
he thought were getting in his way
when responding to extremist plots in
michigan trump showed he knew how to use
the power of a mob
to advance his political objectives
beginning in march
trump leveled attacks on mission
michigan governor gretchen whitmer
for the coronavirus policies in her
state
on march 17th the day after governor
whitmer pushed the federal government to
better support the states
on covet 19 trump criticized her
handling of the pandemic
tweeting failing michigan governor must
work harder and be much more proactive
we are pushing her to get the job done i
stand with michigan
march 27th he added i love michigan
one of the reasons we're doing such a
great job for them during this horrible
pandemic
yet your governor gretchen half whitmer
is weighing over her head she doesn't
have a clue
likes blaming everyone for her own
ineptitude
hashtag mega by april trump's rhetorical
attacks and name calling
turned to calls for mass mobilization of
his supporters
this was a sign of things to come on
april
17 2020 he tweeted quote
liberate michigan
not even two weeks later on april 30th
his supporters marched on the michigan
state capitol in lansing
they stormed the building
trump's marching orders were followed by
aggressive
action on the ground
this video shows these militant
protesters showed up ready to take a
violent stand they came
armed and tightly packed themselves in
the building with no regard of course
for social distancing
this trump-inspired mob may indeed look
familiar to you
confederate battle flags maga hats
weapons camo army gear just like the
insurrectionists
who showed up and invaded this chamber
on january 6th
the siege of the michigan state house
was effectively
a state-level dress rehearsal for the
siege of the u.s
capitol that trump incited on january
6th
it was a preview of the coming
insurrection
president trump's response to these two
events
was strikingly similar following the
armed siege in lansing president trump
refused to condemn the attacks on the
michigan capital
or denounce the violent lawbreakers
instead he did just the opposite
he upheld the righteousness of his
violent followers cause
and he put pressure on the victim of the
attack
to listen to his supporters the day
after the mob attack in lansing
trump told governor whitmer to negotiate
with the extremists
tweeting that the governor should just
quote give a little
to the violent men who had stormed the
capitol
threatening not only the stability of
the michigan government
but her own life as you can see he
tweeted
the governor of michigan should give a
little and put out the fire
these are very good people but they are
angry
they want their lives back again safely
see
them talk to them make a deal
the president says heavily armed
extremists carrying confederate battle
flags
and pushing past police to overtake the
michigan state house chamber
are very good people and just negotiate
with them
it's clear he doesn't think that they're
at fault in any way at all
but april 30th wasn't the only time
trump supporters stormed
michigan capital emboldened by his
praise
and his encouragement and support they
escalated again
governor whitmer refused to capitulate
to the president's demand to negotiate
with them
two weeks later on may 14th trump's mob
again
stormed the state capitol this time
as you can see here one man brought a
doll with a noose around the neck
foreshadowing the appearance of the
large gallows erected outside of this
building
downstairs from here on january 6th as
the crowd chanted
and i still can hear the words ringing
my ear hang mike pence
hang mike pence hang mike pence over the
coming months
even after a crowd threatening governor
whitmer yes yes welcome
everybody thank you for welcoming me um
it's it's been a very busy day i know
we're running late but i'm here
we um it's it's all happening we had a
bunch of stuff to film but i made it i
made it and we we're seeing the last
couple of hours i think of the
prosecution's case house managers then
it will go over to trump's defense
council i believe today as far as i know
that's still scheduled for happening
today
we learned yesterday that a bunch of
republican senators were
sleeping um chuck grassley reportedly
snuck in a tablet and was reading rand
paul wasn't even in there for long
periods of time
um mike braun i believe it was was
straight out
asleep so quite a day yesterday
as uh heretofore unseen
video of what happened on january 6 was
presented
and a lot of very crazy things so let's
um
let's listen and there will be much to
discuss
there will be many many things coming
the effing governor one of those men has
already pled guilty to this conspiracy
the plot was well organized just like
the one that was coming
on january the 6th
the men in michigan even considered
building molotov cocktails to disarm
police vehicles
and attempted to construct their own
ieds something that
actually happened here on january 6th
police authorities arrested extremists
who had weapons and materials
to build explosive devices including one
man found with an assault rifle and
enough materials
to make 11 molotov cocktails
on september 17 2020 one of the michigan
conspiracies posted
when the time comes there will be no
need
to strike fear through presence
the fear will be manifested through
bullets
and what did donald trump do as
president of the united states
to defend one of our nation's governors
against a plotted
kidnapping by violent insurrectionists
did he publicly condemn
violent domestic extremists who hoped
and planned
to launch a civil war in america
no not at all he further inflamed them
by continuing to attack the governor who
was the object
of their hatred in this kidnapping
conspiracy
the very night this conspiracy became
public
and that governor whitmer learned that
there were 13 men who were planning to
kidnap
and likely kill her trump did not
condemn the violence
he did not criticize the extremists he
didn't even check on governor whitmer
safety
he chose to vilify governor wimmer again
and then amazingly took credit for
foiling the plot against her
demanding her gratitude and then he
quickly of course
changed the subject to antifa he tweeted
governor whitmer has done a terrible job
he demanded that she thank him for the
law enforcement operation
that had foiled the kidnapping
conspiracy that had been encouraged
by his rhetoric on october 17th
a little over a week after these people
were arrested for preparing
to kidnap gretchen whitmer trump riled
up a boisterous crowd and muskegon
with more slashing personal attacks on
whitmer driving the crowd to chant
lock her up lock her up he had now
seen that some of his followers were
prepared to engage
in criminal violence with orchestrated
attacks
deadly weapons and willing bodies to
storm a state capitol building
and to attack his perceived political
enemies
and so as the crowd chanted lock her up
he pivoted to his next goal
he told them they couldn't trust the
governor to administer fair elections in
michigan
he used a crowd that he knew would
readily engage in violence
to prepare his followers for his next
and of course his paramount political
objective
claiming the election was stolen and
inciting insurrectionary
action and he did it again on october
27th
during a pre-election rally speech in
lansing michigan
where the capitol had been stormed trump
openly joked with the crowd
about critics saying his words had
provoked
the violent plot against governor
whitmer check it out it's telling
we gotta get her going i don't think she
likes me tuma
great event see i don't comment on that
because every time if i make just even a
little bit of a nod
they say the president led them on no
you i don't have to leave you out
even a little nod they say the president
said
your governor at the urging of her
husband who has abused our sister very
badly
the only man allowed in the state of
michigan the only man allowed to go
sailing
is her husband now your governor i don't
think she likes me too much
hey hey hey hey i'm the one it was our
people that
helped her out with her problem and
we'll have to see if it's a problem
joe biden needs to unite us with these
people
somehow our people my people our people
that helped her out
so president trump offered them a little
winking inside joke
about his constant incitement of the mob
and how much can actually be
communicated by him
with just a little nod just a little nod
he presided over another pounding
rhythmic rendition of his trademark
chant lock her up locked her up
then referring to the fbi's foiling
of the kidnapping conspiracy which was
deadly serious
he said that he helped her out with the
problem maybe it was a problem maybe it
wasn't
i'll have to see maybe it was a problem
maybe it wasn't the president of the
united states of america
he could not bring himself to publicly
oppose
a kidnapping and potential assassination
conspiracy plot against a sitting
governor of one of our 50 states
trump knew exactly what he was doing
in inciting the january 6th mob of
course
exactly he had just seen how easily his
words and actions
inspire violence in michigan he sent a
clear
message to his supporters he encouraged
planning
and conspiracies to take over capital
buildings and threaten
public officials who refuse
is there any chance donald trump was
surprised by the results of his own
incitement
he was surprised how well it went let's
do what
tom payne told us to do use our common
sense
the sense we have in common
is citizens if we don't draw the line
here what's next
what makes you think the nightmare with
donald trump and his law making and
violent mobs
is over
if we let him get away with it and then
it comes to your state capital
or comes back here again what are we
going to say
these prior acts of incitement cast a
harsh light on trump's
obvious intent obvious intent
his unavoidable knowledge of the
consequences
of his incitement the unavoidable
knowledge of the consequences
of his incitement and the clear
foreseeability
of the violent harm that he unleashed on
our people
in our republic january 6 was not some
unexpected radical break from his normal
law-abiding
and peaceful disposition this was his
state of mind
this was his essential m.o
he knew that egged on by his tweets his
lies and his promise of a wild time
in washington to guarantee his grip on
power
his most extreme followers would show up
bright and early
ready to attack ready to engage in
violence
ready to fight like hell for their hero
just like they'd answered his call in
michigan president trump
has said over and over his supporters
are loyal in his own words his
supporters
are the most loyal that we've seen in
our country's history
and he knew that his most hardcore
supporters were willing to direct
violence at elected officials
indeed to attack and lay siege
to a capitol building and he knew they
would be ready
to heed his call on january 6 to stop
the steel
by using violence to block the peaceful
transfer of power
in the united states
he knew they were coming he brought them
here and he welcomed them with open arms
we hear you and love you from the oval
office my dear colleagues is there any
political leader in this room
who believes that if he is ever allowed
by the senate to get back into the oval
office
donald trump would stop inciting
violence
to get his way would you bet the lives
of more police officers on that
would you bet the safety of your family
on that trump would
would you bet the future of your
democracy on that
president trump declared his conduct
totally appropriate
so he gets back into office and it
happens again
we'll have no one to blame but ourselves
is ted liu next there looks like ted
lou's getting ready to come up
mr lou will return now to tell you about
president trump's total lack of remorse
after the insurrection
remorse can you imagine remorse
it's trump we're talking about
thanks to randy robarge by the way for
signing up on my website i appreciate it
good afternoon my colleagues
walked you through president trump's
actions leading up to january 6
and then the horrific events on january
6.
and we saw both during their attack as
well as the days
after the attack that this was a
president
who showed no remorse and took no
accountability
in fact quite the opposite as
representative raskin showed you
president trump claimed that his actions
were quote
totally appropriate their assertion
that everyone thought donald trump's
actions were totally appropriate
including people in this room is of
course
untrue it is also dangerous
sorry guys people are yelling at me yes
thank you also to the 16 twitch subs i
do see them now i'm getting caught up on
everything thank you officials
state and local officials all
unequivocally confirmed
what we witness with our own eyes
that donald trump's conduct was wrong
it was destructive dishonorable and
unamerican
president trump's lack of remorse and
refusal to take accountability during
the attack
shows his state of mind it shows that he
intended the events of january 6
to happen and when it did he delighted
in it
president trump's lack of remorse and
refusal
to take accountability after the attack
poses its own unique and continuing
danger it sends the message
that it is acceptable to incite a
violent
insurrection to overthrow the will of
their people
and that a present united states can do
that and well trump thinks it is
acceptable many of his followers
why we have to hold president trump
accountable
to send a message that is never
patriotic
to incite a violent attack against our
nation's capital
and that future presidents will know
that they cannot follow in donald
trump's
footsteps and get away with it
so let's start with the day of the
attack
on insurrection day january 6
president trump did not once condemn the
attack
i hope they play the video even once
even when he finally asked the violent
extremists
to go home which was three hours
after attack began he sends this video
yes and he ends it with you're very
special
we love you that was his message to
people who perpetrated
this violent gruesome attack roll the
clip
we love you and then two hours later
he tweets remember this day forever
this is not a man who showed remorse
but it's worse than that after that
tweet
it took him another full day to even
condemn
the attack itself the very next day
president trump was eerily silent
and then at 7 01 pm
he releases a pre-recorded video and
there
president trump for the first time
nearly 30 hours after attack began
acknowledges and condemns the violence
mayhem that occurred
he said the demonstrators defiled the
seed of american democracy
he said that these demonstrators didn't
represent this country
and if they broke the law they would pay
but even in that video he says more lies
he says in that very same video that he
immediately deployed
national guard lie that again
is not true the national
guard was not deployed until over
two hours after attack began at a
around 3 pm
because of this late deployment the
national guard did not arrive until
after
5 pm and when the guard was deployed
the pentagon had released a statement
that showed the list of people
and you saw that list of folks that were
consulted
before deploying national guard several
people were on that list
including the vice president president
trump was not on that list
and you know as a veteran
i find it deeply dishonorable that our
commander-in-chief
did not protect us and then later
he tries to take credit for something he
failed to do
shameful also in that video
it's not even taking credit for putting
out a fire you started
it's falsely taking credit for putting
out a fire you started to acceptance of
responsibility for his actions
absent from that video was a call to his
most fervent supporters
to never do this again
and here was his final message in that
so-called
condemnation of attack video oh here we
go what he actually said
please play it and to all of my
wonderful supporters
i know you are disappointed but i also
want you to know
that our incredible journey is only
just beginning president trump not only
failed to show remorse
or take accountability he made clear
he is just beginning
for days he did not address the nation
after this attack
we needed our commander-in-chief to lead
to unite a grieving country
to comfort us but what did president
trump do
nothing silence
we're all aware that a violent mob
murdered
a police officer it took president trump
three days before he lowered the flag of
the united states of america
three days and he did that under protest
and president trump who was
commander-in-chief
at the time did not attend
and pay respects to the officer who lay
in state in the very building
that he died defending obviously he
wasn't there
now some people have argued
that president trump made a mistake
that he gets a mulligan but we know
president trump
didn't make a mistake because you see
when you
or i make a mistake and something very
bad happens
we would show remorse right we would
accept responsibility
we might apologize president trump
didn't do any of that
why not because he intended
what happened on january 6.
and how do we know that he told us
on january 12th as president trump was
boarding air force one to head to texas
and you saw this video before and i'm
going to show it again
he was asked by a reporter quote what is
your role and what happened
at the capitol what is your personal
responsibility
and this was his response my
speech and my words and my final
paragraph my final sentence
and everybody to the key thought it was
totally appropriate
perfect speech on january 12 president
trump
has seen the violent attack on the
capitol he knew the people that died
and his message to all of us was that
his conduct was totally appropriate
i'm a former prosecutor and we're
trained to recognize
lack of remorse yeah but it doesn't take
a prosecutor
i was gonna say exactly that that
president trump was not showing remorse
a nine-year-old could tell he was
showing defiance
he was telling us that he would do this
again
that he could do this again that he and
future presidents
can run for national election lose the
election
inflame the supporters for months and
then incite an insurrection
and that that would be totally
appropriate
one week after the attack on january
13th
president trump in response to
continuing bipartisan criticism
releases another video uh-oh here is
part of what he said
i want to be very clear i unequivocally
condemn the violence
that we saw last week seven days later
violence and vandalism have absolutely
no place in our country
and no place in our movement now that
it's failed to get me in the oven
trump of course had to make that
statement he needed to unequivocally
condemn
the attack but he also needed to mean
those words
you saw donald trump tweet endless
attacks sometimes 108 tweets in a day
and in public speeches and across
rallies repeating words of fight
and stop the steal and never surrender
you know what it looks like when
president trump wants to convey
a message forcefully loudly and
repeatedly he does that
this video sent after a week of the
attack was
not that and we know this because
in this video he again does not show
remorse
does not take responsibility he again
does not acknowledge his role
in the insurrection he does not say in
that video for example
everything i said in the months prior
went too far
and he does not say the one sentence
that matters
he does not say the one sentence that
would stop
future political violence the election
was not stolen he still hasn't said that
sentence
that is why national guard troops and
full body armor
still patrol outside
reports from white house also confirmed
that president trump believed he was
quote forced
by the bipartisan fear after this
russian to acknowledge the new
administration
we know he did not stand behind his
belay combination
because those around him confirmed it
in behind closed doors sources confirmed
that president trump still refused
to directly acknowledge his election
loss to joe biden
and refused to even attend the peaceful
transition of power
the first president in modern history
president trump even reportedly while
watching the impeachment vote
quote focused his ire on republicans who
voted for his
impeachment peppering aides with
questions about
what he could do to exact repent
president trump has made clear of course
that if he is not held accountable
he will not be accountable he will not
stop
now president trump would have his base
in the world
believe that his conduct was totally
appropriate
it is important to impeach that
falsehood
to make clear to his supporters and
everyone watching
that what donald trump did was not
acceptable in fact quite the opposite
people in his own party state officials
former officials current officials
members of congress
have all unambiguously and passionately
said that what donald trump did was
quote
disgraceful shameful
and it called his behavior existential
and wrong and they said that his actions
gave rise to one of the darkest chapters
in united states history
let's hear what some of these officials
had to say
here are governors spencer cox charlie
baker
mike dewine larry hogan and phil scott
that's all republicans right people have
to be held accountable and yes that
includes the president it's important to
remember
that they were the culmination of months
of president trump repeating
over and over again that the american
electoral system
is a fraud after we stoked the flames of
outrage for weeks
leading up to the events of yesterday he
refused to adequately prepare the u.s
capitol for the possibility of violence
and left it nearly defenseless
his remarks during and after the
travesty of the attack on the capital
were disgraceful
president trump's continued refusal to
accept the election results
without producing credible evidence of a
rigged election
it started a fire that has threatened to
burn down our democracy
this incendiary speech yesterday
when he gave proceeding the march
that he gave to the protesters
served only to fan those flames
i proudly stood by my father's side at
age 12.
on the floor of the house chamber as we
both
took the oath of office an oath to
support and defend
the constitution of the united states
it's clear to me that president trump
has
abandoned this sacred oath
seeing our capital a symbol of democracy
around the world
stormed by an angry mob was
heartbreaking
and let me be clear these actions
were not patriotic and these people
are not patriots the fact these flames
of hate and insurrection were lit by the
president of the united states
will be remembered as one of the darkest
chapters in our nation's history
one of the darkest chapters in our
nation's history
former members of the trump
administration long-standing republicans
also made clear that president trump
incited
this insurrection and it went against
our democracy
the president's former secretary of
defense james mattis
declared that today's violent assault on
our capital
an effort to subjugate american
democracy by mob
rule was fomented by mr trump
former white house chief of staff john
kelly also spoke on this as well
and i'd like to play an audio clip of
what he said
what happened on capitol hill against
there is a direct result of his
you know poisoning the minds of people
with the lies and
the frauds if you couldn't hear that
what john cauley said about
president trump was that what happened
on capitol hill
was a direct result of him poisoning the
minds of people
with their lies and their fraud
former speaker of the house john boehner
declared that
quote the invasion of our capital by
imam
incited by lies from some entrusted with
power is a disgrace to all who
sacrificed to build
our republic
this was echoed by former trump official
after former
trump official here is where former
national security advisors john bolton
h.r mcmaster former white house
communications director alyssa farah
and former chief of staff mick mulvaney
said
let me just ask you do you think
president trump has blood on his hands
i think he does look i agree with bill
barr i think he did incite
this mob with the clear intention of
having them disrupt the
electoral college certification and
delay it to give him more time i don't
think there's any
question about it there are many reasons
for this assault on the capitol
but foremost among them was the
president's exhortations was the
president's sustained
disinformation we've seen a president
stoking fears
amidst these crisis first and foremost i
want to say that
what happened at the capitol was
unacceptable
an american undemocratic i i think
everybody recognizes that what happened
on wednesday
is different you could go down the long
not everybody
that people complained about with donald
trump and i could probably defend almost
all of them many of them were policy uh
differential uh
or differences many of them were
stylistic differences
but wednesday was different wednesday
was existential wednesday is one of
those things that struck to the very
heart
of what it means to be an american and
it was wrong
mick mulvaney president trump's former
chief of staff
is clearly saying what we all felt
that january 6 was different
it was existential it was wrong
it was un-american
and this sentiment was echoed not just
from people
outside the administration but from
people inside
the trump administration perhaps most
telling
was the flood of resignations from
people inside
president trump's administration with
percent access
to president trump his own officials
felt so betrayed by his conduct
that numerous officials resigned is it
awkward to be mitch mcconnell and see
your wife up on that list
trump's term 16 officials
resigned in protest 16.
they all took this dramatic action of
resigning
because they saw the clear link between
president trump's conduct
and the violent insurrection
here is some some of what they said
secretary devos
who was an administration oh they're
doing an elaine channel that's great
in her resignation letter that quote
there's no mistaking the impact your
rhetoric had on the situation
and it is an inflection point for me
secretary chao who was in administration
their entire term
explained yesterday our country
experienced a traumatic
and entirely avoidable event as
available
the president stormed the capitol
building following a rally he addressed
as i'm sure is the case with many of you
it has deeply troubled me in a way i
simply
cannot set aside
deputy costello told his associates the
attack was his
quote breaking point and he hoped quote
a wake-up call these
rebukes and resignations from president
trump's own administration
made clear that president trump's
conduct
was anything but totally appropriate
they also remind us that this can and
must be
a wake-up call as representative fred
upton so eloquently put it president
trump expressed
no regrets for last week's violent
instruction at the u.s capitol
this sends exactly the wrong signal
to those of us who support the very core
of our democratic principles
and took a solemn oath to the
constitution
it is time to say enough is
enough now no one is saying here that
president trump cannot contest the
election
of course he can but what president
trump did
as his former chief ex chief of staff
explained
was different it was dishonorable
it was un-american and it resulted in
fatalities
president trump spent months inflaming
his supporters
spread lie i see a lot of people asking
when the defense starts so
i believe correct me if i'm wrong people
who in the chat
yesterday they they used about six of
their eight hours
the impeachment managers so my thought
is that they had about two hours left
and um from what i'm seeing they've
already been going 75
minutes so is it crazy to think they the
the prosecution only has about 45
minutes left maybe i'm wrong about that
the same thing
that's why lack of remorse is an
important factor in impeachment
because impeachment conviction
and disqualification is not oh it's
eight hours per day oh my god
wow that's insane it's making sure
that no future official no future
president
wowza does the same exact thing
president trump does
president trump's live remorse shows
that he will undoubtedly cause future
harm if
allowed because he still refuses to
account
for his previous high grave crime
against our government
you know i'm not afraid of donald trump
running again in four years
i'm afraid he's gonna run again and lose
because he can do this again right
what an unusual situation because
despite president trump's claim that
everyone thinks what he did was fine
so many have come out and spoken so
strongly passionately
about what happened here
i'd like to highlight statement by
representative anthony gonzalez
he said the vice president both chambers
of congress had their lives put in grave
danger as a result of the president's
actions and the events leading up to and
on
january 6. during the attack itself
the president abandoned his post while
many members asked for help
thus furthering endangering all present
these are fundamental threats not just
in people's lives but the very
foundation
of our republic
and now i'd like to show what members of
congress said
leading up to the most bipartisan
impeachment vote in u.s history
because i do want everyone watching
especially president trump's supporters
to see firsthand what i believe
we all feel that what president trump
did was not
appropriate that it was not american and
that it absolutely
can not stand
what he has done and what he has caused
here um
is something that we've never seen
before in our history trump furious with
liz chang all indications are that the
president has become
unmoored not just from his duty nor even
his of but from reality
itself the president's role in this
insurrection is undeniable
both on social media ahead of january 6
and in his speech that day
he deliberately promoted baseless
theories creating a combustible
environment
of misinformation and division to allow
the president united states to incite
this attack without consequences
is a direct threat to the future of this
democracy
after this trial i hope you'll come
together
and cast your vote and make absolutely
clear how we as a congress
and as a nation feel about what donald
trump did
by convicting him and to prevent this
from being only the beginning as
president trump said
and to deter future presidents who do
not like the outcome of a national
election
from believing they can follow in
president trump's footsteps
it is what our constitution requires
it is what our country deserves
powerful presentation from ted lou jamie
raskin coming back up to the lectern
representative degette will now return
to show how extremists were
emboldened by the insurrection and plan
to attack the inauguration
thanks to forsaken menu scourge or
scourge depending on your preference and
chris for their twitch subs appreciate
it
and also kara rozier at joinedpakman.com
thanks cara my colleagues have showed
you
the overwhelming evidence of how
president trump's conduct
assembled incited and inflamed the mob
we showed how and why this attack
this violence was not only foreseeable
but preventable we showed that president
trump
knew his conduct could and would result
in violence
and that when the attack occurred he did
not fulfill his duty as
commander-in-chief
and defend us instead he was delighted
donald trump incited a violent
insurrection
and he failed to defend our nation our
capital
this congress and our law enforcement
from the attack he incited
now i want to turn to the impact the
long-term
harm of this conduct i hope they have
interviews with some of those wacky
supporters
through the breadth and gravity of this
harm
i'd like to start with the effect
president trump's conduct
had on our domestic security
we saw firsthand how donald trump's
conduct emboldened and escalated
domestic violence extremists
these folks are known in the law
enforcement community
as dves these threats were
and are made worse by president trump's
refusal to take accountability
and his refusal to forcibly denounce
what his
own fbi identified as some of the most
dangerous elements of our country
elements
even as the attack was underway he
tweeted words of support
to his violent supporters and then in
the aftermath on january 7th
president trump made it clear this was
only
the beginning and to all of my wonderful
supporters
i know you are disappointed but i also
want you to know
that our incredible journey is only
just beginning
and he was right unless we take action
the violence is only just beginning
in the aftermath of the attack we saw a
huge rise
in threats to our from domestic violent
extremists
including specific threats to the
inauguration in dc
and also to all 50 state capitals
our intelligence agencies confirmed that
in addition to these specific threats
president trump's conduct emboldened the
very
same violent groups who initiated the
attack
and sparked new violent coalitions
these groups believe that they're
following his orders
they believe that their acts of
insurrection and violence
are patriotic
violence is never patriotic and it's
never american
it's not the democratic way and it's not
the republican way
after the attack it's increasingly the
republican defense and
law enforcement agencies reported an
increasing credible threats to the
inauguration
from donald trump's supporters on
january 13
2021 a joint intelligence bulletin
issued by the department of homeland
security the fbi
and the national counterterrorism center
found quote
since the sixth january event violent
online rhetoric regarding the 20 january
presidential inauguration has increased
with some calling for unspecified quote
justice for the sixth january fatal
shooting
by law enforcement of a participant who
had illegally entered the capitol
building
and another posting that quote many
armed individuals would return on 19
january
the agencies also made clear why these
threats were escalating
especially regarding the inauguration
the report explained that a primary
motivating factor was quote the shared
false
narrative of a stolen election
and opposition to the change in control
of the executive
and legislative branches of the federal
government
may lead some individuals to adopt the
belief
that there is no political solution to
address that their grievances
and that violent action is necessary
in other words president trump's
spreading of inflammatory disinformation
about the election
incited the insurrection on january 6
and may lead to further violence online
just as they did one of the things i
think they've done a good job of
showing here is you can't just look at
the words
on january 6th and say either these
words did or didn't directly cause what
happened on january 6th
telling everybody it's been stolen from
them for two months
is part of that case and i think they're
doing a good job showing that
social media websites made further plans
for violence
they posted quote many of us
will return on january 19 2021
carrying our weapons in support of our
nation's resolve
to which the world will never forget we
will come
in numbers no standing army or police
agency can match
quote we took the building once and we
can take it again
other users eager to participate in
additional attacks
confirmed that they were waiting on
president trump's instructions
about what to do next referring to a
future planned attack
a user on the online platform known as
gab posted quote
i'd like to come do this but want to
know
does our president want us there
awaiting
instructions in fact in the days leading
up to the inauguration
multiple individuals potential many
potentially an attempt to carry out the
plots that i just previewed
were arrested in washington dc including
on serious weapons charges
one of those men was coulee griffin the
founder of cowboys for trump
who took part in the capital attack and
was also arrested on january 17th
here's what he said for hit about his
plans for violence
you know you want to say that that was a
a mob
you want to say that was a violence no
sir
no ma'am no we could have a second
amendment rally on those same steps that
we had that rally yesterday
you know and if we do then it's going to
be a sad day because you're going to be
against the law
thrown it out of that building but at
the end of the day you mark my word
we will plant our flag on the desk of
nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
so so he's saying everybody could break
the law and despite not being licensed
to carry in washington dc they would
bring their guns anyway that's what he's
saying we could all become immediate
criminals the capital
where all of us are right now
now the name cui griffin may sound
familiar because he previously faced
controversy for a may 2020 video
where he said quote the only good
democrat is a dead group
democrat hear it from him yourself
a lot of people getting banned by the
way i've come to the conclusion that
the only good democrat is a dead
democrat
edgy now when he said this
president trump actually retweeted
griffin
and thanked him for that sentiment
when donald trump retweeted this he was
no stranger to griffin in march
2019 over a year earlier
griffin and trump had spoken on the
phone for nearly 30 minutes
right president trump's conduct without
a doubt
made it clear he supported griffin in
fact
griffin even said so himself
as griffin later said about president
trump retweeting his inflammatory it
really meant a lot to the dead democrats
quote it really means a lot to me
because i know the president of the
united states
has my back oh remember this is a man
who was
here on january 6th that was
metaphorically arrested
after threatening to come back here to
make blood
come running out of this building
threats like griffins have triggered a
deployment of forces
the likes of which we have never seen
there were approximately 25 000
national guard troops brought in from
around the country
to protect dc leading up to
and on inauguration day as you know
many of those troops are still here take
a look at that
is she pointing to troops in the room
these were scenes that played out all
over the country
five days following the siege on the
capitol on january
11 2021 the fbi warned that quote
armed protests are being planned at all
50 state capitals
from 16 january through at least 20
january
and at the u.s capitol from 17 january
through 20
january as a result at least
21 states activated their national
guards in preparation for potential
attacks
president trump's incitement has
reverberated around the country
prompting massive law enforcement
mobilization
in several state capitals including
washington
illinois michigan and georgia
look at these photos this is what donald
trump has done to america
this massive deployment of law
enforcement has
cost the taxpayers dearly the national
guard deployment to dc
alone is expected to cost at least 480
million dollars
the bills are already also racking up in
the states
north carolina south carolina
pennsylvania utah and wisconsin have
each spent
about a half a million dollars to
safeguard their capitals in the run-up
to the inauguration
ohio spent 1.2 million dollars
over the same two-week period and
remember
this is at a time when state budgets are
already suffering
under the weight of the pandemic our
brave service members showed up
thanks to their dedication and their
vigilance
the inauguration and the days leading up
to it mercifully
proceeded without incident in fact
after news broke of law enforcement's
preparedness for further attacks
leaders of the proud boys the three
percenters militia
the organizers of the million magumar
they all now told their followers to
avoid protests
up to or leading up to the inauguration
for fear that law enforcement would
crush them
and arrest rioters who showed up
thank god uh oh
oh no it wasn't an insurrection sequel
here on january 20th
but look at the price we've
buying it's not just dollars and cents
this capital has become a fortress as
state capital state capitals have all
across the country
our constituents no longer have access
to the elected representatives
every democrat and republican including
people who came here on january
6 peacefully is paying the price
and it's not just a loss of access it's
a dimming of their freedom
it's a dimming of all of our freedom we
must uphold our oaths
as the tens of thousands of law
enforcement officers have done in the
wake of january 6th
because if we do not president trump's
mob stands ready
for more attacks now this should be no
surprise
having a commander-in-chief who incites
violence
has given life to the existing violent
groups he spent
years cultivating and has inspired new
coalitions among extremist groups who
actually view january as a success
according to the fbi president trump's
assemblage of his mob
was particularly dangerous because quote
in-person engagement between dves
of differing ideological goals during
the capital breach
likely serve to foster connections which
may
increase dve's willingness capability
and motivation to attack and undermine
a government they view as illegitimate
in other words they all got to talking
to each other
this bulletin by our own intelligence
committee
was also confirmed by concrete evidence
rioters celebrated their roles in the
january 6th attack on social media
they boasted about their success in
breaching the capital
and forcing members of congress and the
vice president to evacuate
take for example right-wing provocateur
nick fuentes
the day before the capital insurrection
fuentes
said this on his international uh-oh
what can you and i do to a state
legislature besides killing
although we should not do that i'm not
advising that but i mean what else can
you do right
right was at the capitol on january 6
and praised the insurrection on a live
stream as glorious
and awe inspiring he later said quote
we forced a joint session of congress
and the vice president
to evacuate because trump supporters
were banging down and then successfully
burst through the doors
fuentes was not the only provocateur to
revel in the violence
according to mike dunn a member of the
boogaloo boys
an anti-government movement whose
adherence helped to lead
aren't the bugala boys good now i heard
from uh jimmy dore that they're good now
working overtime to capitalize on the
january 6th riots
and hope it will lead to more action
they said quote
just know there's more to come
proud boys members were bragging about
the attack on the capitol
one post on the proud boys telegram
channel said
people say see saw what we can do they
know what we're up to they know
and we they want in the leader of the
proud boys himself
sent the same message enrique tario said
the proud boys would be active during
biden's presidency
tario stated you're definitely going to
see more of us extremist groups are also
boasting
that the attack on our capital is a boon
for their recruitment efforts
three percent or chris hill says he's
been contacted by
several people interested in joining
since the interac insurrection
and as one expert who focuses on
domestic extremism
jared holt explained by all
measurable effects this was a far
oh boy a right extremist one of the most
successful attacks
that they've ever launched they're
talking about this
as the first stab in a greater
revolution
and as indicated by mr holt their
perceived success has given them
encouragement to continue and to
escalate attacks
intelligence agencies have also noted
that these
extremist groups will unfortunately be
targeting vulnerable minority
communities in the u.s
a january 27 2021 dhs bulletin
warned quote long-standing racial and
ethnic tension of the sort
that led to a man killing 23 people
at an el paso walmart will continue to
grow and motivate further attacks
the january 13 joint intelligence
bulletin report
stated that in addition to the other
types of violence listed
dves may be incited to carry out
more violence including violence against
racial ethnic and religious minorities
and associated institutions journalists
members of the lgbtq plus community
and other targets common among some dves
these prejudice elements could be seen
visibly
in the attack that in the crowd that
attacked the capital
pictured here is robert packer
robert packer is an avowed white
supremacist and holocaust denier
who proudly wore that sweatshirt which
states quote
camp auschwitz these prejudiced elements
could also be heard from the crowds
as you've heard the insurrectionists
that attacked the capitol on january 6
hurled racial slurs including at black
police officers
one officer described the trauma he
experienced
when the rioter seized the capital he
said quote
i'm a black officer there was a lot of
racism that day
i was called racial slurs and in the
moment i didn't process this as
traumatic
i was just trying to survive i just
wanted to get home
to see my daughter again i couldn't show
weakness
final i finally reached a safe place
surrounded by officers
i was able to cry to let it out
to attempt to process it
these extremist groups were emboldened
because president trump
told them repeatedly that their
insurrectus
insurrectionist activities were the
pinnacle
of patriotism well
let today be the day that we we reclaim
the definition of patriotism impeachment
is not to punish
but to prevent we are not here to punish
donald trump
we are here to prevent the seeds of
hatred that he planted
from bearing any more fruit as my
colleague showed
this was not the first time that
president trump invite inspired violence
but it must be the last time
that he's given a platform to do so
this must be our wake-up call we must
condemn it
because the threat is not over
president trump refused to condemn this
type of violence
instead over and over again
he's encouraged it our response must be
different this time
we simply cannot sweep this under the
rug
we must take a united stand all of us
that this is not american
think back to august 2017 when a young
woman was
murdered during a white supremacist
rally in charlottesville west virginia
her name was heather heyer her mother's
name is susan bro
miss bro has been a steadfast advocate
for her daughter's memory
in a 2018 interview she expressed
concern that people had rushed too
quickly
to recreation without accountability
uh if you rush to heal if you rush to
everybody grab
oh man something seems up with this
c-span feed i'm just gonna reset it for
us um
each other in cincum by the way so
hopefully we're better off
right back here on a few from the
standpoint of streams
fiber connection
we're not just back where we were i
would argue
things are worse in 2017
it was unfathomable to most of us to
think that charlottesville could happen
just as it was unfathomable to most of
us
that the capital could have been
breached on january 6th
frankly what unfathomable horrors await
us
if we do not stand up now and say no
this is not america
and we will not just express condolences
and denunciations
we won't just close the book and try to
move on
we will act to make sure
this never happens again
closing the book there and then we will
hear from jamie raskin
representative cicilline and lou will
now come to show the harm done
and the damage done to congress and our
democratic process
all right mr sicilini
congressman celini from rhode island
will speak
president distinguished senators
you just heard from my colleague manager
to get how the conduct of donald trump
dramatically increased the threats to
our security
and embolden violent domestic
extremists i'd like to now turn to the
harm that
was caused here inside these walls
as a result of the conduct on january 6.
the harm to us
to congress to those who serve our
country
and to the constitutional processes as
the trump mob
tried to stop the election certification
process
the attack on january 6 was one of the
bloodiest
intrusions in the capital since the
british
invaded in the war of 1812 and burned it
to the ground
and you've heard in painstaking detail
that the president's mob
posed an immediate and serious threat to
the continuity and constitutional
succession
of the united states government as the
first
second and third lines of the presidency
the vice president
the speaker of the house the president
pro tem
all together and faced a common threat
in the same location
and we've seen the first and the second
were purposely targeted
by these attackers these weren't idle
threats
the mob as you have heard chanted hang
mike pence
the charging documents show that the
writers said they would have killed
vice president pence and speaker pelosi
had they found them
dawn bancroft and diane santos smith
two of the riders charged in the attack
were caught on tape
discussing the brutal violence that they
hoped to inflict on speaker pelosi
has she not been rushed out to safety
they said quote
we broke into the capitol we got inside
we did our part
we were looking for nancy to shoot her
in the frigging brain
but we didn't find her end quote
senators simply put this mob was trying
to
overthrow our government they came
perilously close to reaching the first
three people in line to the presidency
it wasn't just the vice president and
the speaker
writers were prepared to attack any
member of congress they found
thomas edward caldwell donovan ray kroll
and jessica marie watkins three militia
members
were also charged for their role in the
attack they discussed trapping us
inside the underground tunnels the
indictment
quote social media chatter with caldwell
quote all members are in the tunnel
under capital seal them in turn on gas
all legislators are down in the tunnels
three floors down do like we had to do
when i was in the core
and start tearing out floors go from top
to bottom end quote
never did any of us imagine that we or
our colleagues
would face mortal peril by a mob
riled up by the president of the united
states
the leader of the free world but we did
all because donald trump could not
accept
his election defeat
trump chose himself above the people
above our institutions above our
democracy
above all of you
you know we've heard trump espouse for
years now this america first
policy but his true north star isn't
america's well-being it's not country
first like
our dear departed colleague john mccain
no he has
directed his trump first no matter the
cost
no matter the threat to our democracy
but each and every one of us in this
room
must agree on one thing we can
never allow the kind of violent attack
that occurred on january 6
to ever happen again in this country
in the immediate aftermath we heard
really disturbing accounts for many
members of congress
about what they experienced that day
here are some of those reactions
following the attack representative
dusty johnson
expressed concerns that we had gotten to
the point where so many of us
had sown the seeds of anger and division
we were barricaded
and there was some fear to be sure
but overwhelmingly the emotion that i
experienced was one of anger
i just could not believe that this was
happening i could not believe that we
had gotten to this point
where so many of us had uh sown these
seeds of anger
and of division and we had built this
powder keg
and really we were starting to see this
powder keg
light up and it was frankly i was
furious
representative jason crowe compared the
events of this day to his time
in afghanistan as an army ranger
something senator reid knows
something about what i felt in the
capital behind us
uh is something that i haven't felt
since i was in afghanistan as an army
ranger and to think that as a member of
congress
in 2021 in the u.s capitol on the house
floor
that i was preparing to fight my way out
of the people's house against a mob
is just beyond troubling
representative pat fallon was humbled by
his experience on january 6 and
described
the events as surreal as they unfolded
here in the capitol
it was something that i just never
thought no i just never thought i'd see
this in
our nation's capital and particularly in
the in the house chamber it was
it was surreal when it was unfolding
well you know and
what what was interesting was the
bravery and the courage of some of my
fellow members
when we got to a point where the mob was
banging on the doors
and all that kept them from reaching
that the chamber
itself was uh the doors
and then some furniture that we had
moved and some capitol police and they
needed to be augmented
and so tony gonzalez a new freshman rep
from texas and rodney jackson
and troy nels and mark wayne mullen
stepped in
and we broke off furniture uh some of
the hand sanitizer stations are
on these big giant poles the wooden
poles and we turned them upside down
and we were ready to actually have the
street fight in the house chamber was
unbelievable
many members that day wondered if they
would ever see their families again
as the rioters reached the capitol and
they were
outnumbered and trapped inside they were
calling loved ones to
say goodbye representative dan kildee
was one of them
listen to how he described the impact of
the ride on him
i was laying on the floor uh trying to
you know protect myself behind this
little wall
and you know we all took our pins off
because we
you know we're certain that if uh this
mob were to come in that that would not
be even think that would be
easily be able to identify us as members
of congress
um and i called my wife and
you know it wasn't until i heard your
voice that i thought
wow you know this is like one of those
calls
you hear about
well most coverage is focused on the
extreme danger posed to members and the
capitol police
who were targets of this attack
there were lots of other people in the
capital working on january 6 as well
from personal aids to floor employees
cleaning staff
food service workers we can't forget all
the people
that were in harm's way that day these
employees experienced
trauma some coward hiding in places
just feet feet away from where this
rabid crowd
had assembled many were just
kids 20 somethings who came here to work
because they believed in their country
and they believed in working to make it
better others were dedicated food and
service workers all
work incredibly hard to make sure that
we can come here and do our jobs
these workers are the lifeblood of the
legislative branch
they deserved better you've already
heard from speaker pelosi's staff the
staff that was
hiding under the conference table
cowering in the dark
making sure that the attackers couldn't
hear them but i'd like to share with you
what some other staffers went through
listen as two staffers recall what they
experienced that day
but then we were seeing on twitter on
our phones and then uh
and hearing from some of the police
officers on the floor that that you know
the building had been breached
you know building breached those were
two words i had never heard
that was particularly stressful
being in a room um
close to to where things are happening
and not
really knowing what was happening um
and seeing it come in live and getting
texts from people
you know are you okay and
truthfully i i didn't know what what was
happening
i heard shots fired shots fired shots
fired show them in your hands show me
your hands
then i did not know if they were right
outside
if they were lots of people with weapons
if there were one shooter if they had
you know i didn't know what it looked
like i just knew that there were shots
fired
um outside of the house chamber
according to reports one republican
senate staff whose office was not far
from the floor
took a steel rod and barricaded his door
as the riders banged on his door trying
to break in
the new york times also reported that a
senior black staffer was on the lockdown
for six
hours during the insurrection was so
disturbed about these events
that she quit her job another staffer
who was on the floor
of the house that day described that
what happened on january 6
still echoes in his mind listen to him
describe the moments just before this
indelible image
i heard glass break and i could see the
um the uh the window panes on the house
main door start to pop and i figured
that you know obviously i knew they were
at the door and they figured out a way
to break the
glass and um and the last thing i
remember before i walked off the floor
was uh several of the police officers
had drawn their guns
and had their guns trained on the door
you know clearly that was
i didn't think there was anything else i
could do and i didn't want to be there
for whatever was about to occur so i got
to the top of the stairs
uh the stairway was was pretty packed
and right about that point
i don't know whether it was a police
officer or somebody else said they're
right behind us
run for me the thing that i keep
thinking about and again there's
there isn't a day that hasn't gone by
since january 6th that at some point in
the day i haven't
kind of gone back and and and picked at
some little thing but
the sound of those window panes popping
um you know i i won't forget that sound
i won't forget that sound
how long will the sound of window panes
breaking haunt this staffer
and he isn't alone there are countless
people who are still living
with the trauma of what happened that
day this includes by the way another
group of people who are with us in the
capital
on that day and that's the press they
were in danger particularly
after years of being derided by
president trump as fake news
kristen wilson a reporter for cnn
recently tweeted about her experience
she said i have 14 people on my team we
were scattered everywhere
two of them were on crutches and
couldn't have run if they had to
they had to anyway one was trapped in
the house chamber and had to crawl out
to hide
four of us barricaded ourselves in a
room off the senate chamber
every bang on the door of them trying to
come through
i can still hear in my head
the janitorial and custodial staff of
the capitol the people who day after day
tend to our home away from home were
also
traumatized but we don't talk about them
and the harm they suffered often enough
one janitorial worker recounted who was
so scared
that he had to hide in a closet during
the attack he said quote i was all by
myself
i didn't know what was going on end
quote
another employee a mother of three said
the insurrection
shattered all my sense of security at
work
an employee of the capital said quote i
hope nothing else
happens because these people were
talking about killing us
killing federal employees killing police
another employee was afraid to work on
inauguration day said
quote i honestly feel for my life i've
got two children at home
end quote for many of the black and
brown staff the trauma was made worse
by the many painful symbols of hate that
were on full display that day
insurrectionists waved confederate flags
and hurled the most disgusting
racial slurs at dedicated capital
workers
then after all that these same workers
many of them people of color were forced
to clean up the mess
left by mobs of white nationalists
one member of the janitorial staff
reflected how terrible he felt
when he had to clean up feces that had
been smeared
on the wall blood of a rioter who had
died
and broken glass and other objects
strewn all over the floor he said
i felt bad i felt degraded
let's also not forget that this violent
attack
happened in the middle of a global
pandemic
social distancing was impossible as we
were hiding for our lives
in cramped quarters for long periods of
time
since january 6 at least seven members
who hid with other members of congress
have tested positive for covet 19. at
least 38 capital police officers
have either tested positive or been
exposed
and not available and they put their
lives in danger
they deserved better than this we all
did
that brings me to the next arm now all
of us in this room
made it out alive but not everyone was
so lucky
three law enforcement officers
tragically lost their lives
as a result of the riot on january 6th
these officers capital police officer
brian siknik
capitol police officer howard liebengood
and metropolitan police officer jeffrey
smith
all honorably served to protect and
defend
my colleague mr swalwell told you about
officer sicknick
he was a 42 year old military veteran
who dedicated his entire life to public
service
on january 6 he fought a mob of rioters
as they streamed into the capitol
and ultimately lost his life protecting
us
officer liebengood was a 15-year veteran
of the capitol police
his father served as sergeant-arms here
in the senate
and officer liebengood followed his
extraordinary example of public service
officer smith served for 12 years with
the metropolitan police department
he heeded the call of duty on january
6th by coming to stand with the capitol
police to help
secure our democracy earlier my
colleague manager swalwell showed you
terrible videos
of the police being physically abused
and injured
you remember what happened to officer
fanon and officer hodges of the mpd
but there were scores of other officers
whose names we don't know were also
brutalized that day
injuries the u.s capitol police and the
metropolitan police department include
concussions
irritated lungs serious injuries caused
by
repeated blows from bats
poles and clubs capitol police officers
also sustained injuries
that will be with them for the rest of
their lives
one officer lost the tip of a right
index finger
in a statement issued on january 7 the
chairman of the capitol police officers
union said and i quote
i have officers who were not issued
helmets prior to the attack
who have sustained brain injuries one
officer has two cracked ribs and two
smashed
spinal discs one officer is going to
lose his eye
and another was stabbed with a metal
fence stake
end quote in total
at least 81 members of capitol police
and 65 members of the metropolitan
police department were injured during
the attack on january 6th
former capitol police chief sun
described the insurrection as
violent unlike anything he'd seen in his
30-year career
in law enforcement d.c police chief
robert j conte iii who had spoken with
an officer who had been
beaten and injured with a stun gun said
quote
i've talked to officers who have done
two tours in iraq
who said this was scarier to them than
their time in combat
end quote of course the physical
violence
is not the only thing that will have a
lasting effect
on our brave sworn officers trump's
mob verbally denigrated their patriotism
questioned their loyalty and yelled
racial slurs
they call them traitors nazis
un-american for protecting us
for example in the next clip a rioter
wearing a hunting jacket
accosts a police officer
not one idea don't touch me bro
okay no
they work for us [ __ ] that
they're rapists listen to how the trump
mob
talked to these officers
you heard that with your own ears
thank you fellas effing trader
so much for backing the blue just a
couple more examples
[ __ ] you guys you can't even call
yourself american
you broke your [ __ ] nose today 1776
[ __ ]
truck
uh i thought it was terrific um it was
clean
it was nice and the bed was good
they called law enforcement officers
traitors
you have to wonder who are these writers
sworn to
to whom do they believe the police owe
their loyalty
to the people to the constitution
to our democracy or to donald trump
even those who are not outwardly injured
the mental toll has been significant
several capital police officers have
reportedly threatened self-harm
in the days following the riot and in
one case an officer voluntarily turned
in her gun
because she was afraid of what might
happen black police officers were also
met with racist
vitriol you heard league manager raskin
reference a black police officer who
weary from racialized violence
that he had experienced that day saying
tears just started streaming down my
face
i said what the f man is this america
is this america lead manager asking
asked
is this america what is your answer to
that question
is this okay if not
what are we going to do about it
these people matter these people who
risk their lives for
us so i ask you respectfully to consider
them
the police officers the staff of this
building
when you cast your vote these people are
in deep
pain because they showed up here to
serve to serve the american people to
serve their
government to serve all of us and i ask
each of you when you cast your vote to
remember them
and honor them and act in service of
them
as they deserve i also want to recognize
that
four individuals for insurrectionists
were who also lost their lives during
the attack
these people were led here by the words
and actions
of an individual who made them believe
that they were patriots
the loss of human life is of course the
most consequential
but that was not the only damage wrought
that day
the trump mob also damaged this building
they defiled some of the most sacred
places
statuary hall the rotunda where some of
america's greatest champions
presidents supreme court justices civil
rights heroes
and other defenders are honored after
their death
trump's violent mob had little respect
for this place
this video shows the wreckage left in
the senate parliamentarian's office
by the insurrectionists
a bust of president zachary taylor was
smeared with
what appeared to be blood an empty
picture frame presumably robbed of its
contents was found on the floor
and videos of the insurrection captured
one man stealing a framed photo
another one tearing a scroll from the
wall and ripping it up
and throwing those pieces on the floor
a sign paying tribute to john lewis was
also
shamefully destroyed and only a broken
piece of the memorial was found on the
ground next to a trash can
the photo of mr lewis was gone the
damage done to this building
is a stain on all of us and on the
dignity
of our democracy thanks the denims for
the raid very much appreciated
certification
stop our democratic process fortunately
they did not prevail newspapers across
america
on january 21st the day after the
inauguration proclaimed democracy has
prevailed president biden said that in
his inauguration speech
the headline was in so many places
because the world's
oldest constitutional democracy and the
principles
underlying it had been attacked and
challenged
this wasn't just an attack on the
capitol building and the dedicated
people inside
it was an attack on what we were elected
to preserve
our democracy this attack on our
elections on the peaceful transfer of
power from
one president to the next didn't even
happen
during the civil war
but it did just happen because of the
cold
calculated and conspiratorial acts of
our former president
donald j trump we showed you that the
insurrectionists were deliberate
that they came looking for vice
president pence and speaker pelosi
ready to kill when president trump
incited a lawless mob to attack
our process he was attacking our
democracy
he was trying to become king
and rule over us against the will of the
people
and the valid results of the election
for the first time ever in our history a
sitting president actively instigated
his supporters
to violently disrupt the process that
provides for the peaceful transfer of
power
from one president to the next
think about that for a moment what if
president trump
had been successful what if he had
succeeded in overturning the will of the
people
in our constitutional processes who
among us
is willing to risk that outcome by
letting trump's
constitutional crimes go unanswered
the founders included impeachment in our
constitution not as a
punishment but to prevent
we have to prevent every president today
tomorrow or anytime in the future from
believing
that this conduct is acceptable
today we have to stand up for our
democracy
and ensure we remain a country governed
by the people for the people
by telling donald trump and people all
across this country
and all across the world that his
crimes will not and cannot stand
congressman sicilini there
i ask unanimous consent the house stand
in recess for 15 minutes
the house that's interesting
the objection without objection the
senate will stand in recess
i guess you can refer to either chamber
as the house the hou that's interesting
i've never heard the senate referred to
as the house um i guess it's sort of
like saying the chamber i don't know
all right we are um we are about uh
well i guess we don't know somewhere
between 25 and 50
of the way through day three
the second day of the prosecution
not expecting to use the full eight
hours that they have
available today there is willard mitt
romney
walking off to wherever he's going to
and we will see a number of the senators
exit
there is another guy and uh this officer
strongly double masked looks like
surgical plus cloth
uh which we're seeing now recommended by
the cdc
uh okay so a lot very very much
happening today and i'm trying to catch
up
with with everything i am going to read
some super chats i know i am way way way
behind on super chats
um so much is going on i want to say
thank you to mila tempest
as well as durgees maddohee ho
scowl disposable and a bunch of other
people
for signing up via twitch six more
people uh just did that
that puts us at 27. i also want to say
a huge thank you to grant westerfield
as well as brian kelly for signing up at
joinpackman.com
as many of you know january was a tough
one from the standpoint of website
memberships it's just tough out there
from the standpoint of
finances for a lot of people uh given
what's going on
and um appreciate everybody who's been
signing up lately the coupon code is
working
absolutely fine the coupon code has not
been deactivated
the coupon code is not case sensitive
the coupon code is working perfectly
at joinpakman.com so consider yourselves
invited to sign up i would love to thank
you momentarily
um let's look at a few super chats that
have been coming in david gitlin says
without anonymous vote this is pointless
well it's not pointless but we know the
outcome is a better way i think i should
say it
dave the base says they should turn the
camera around and show the gop senators
reading and sleeping
yes i have a report about that today on
our podcast
i hope all of you are subscribed to the
podcast it's free
um and we talk about rand paul was
missing for a bunch of yesterday
mike braun was sleeping like really
asleep
chuck grassley reportedly snuck in a
tablet
of some kind and had it kind of placed
where it looked like he was just looking
down at his desk but he was he was
reading on a tablet
it's crazy what's going on um
some senators reportedly just touring
the senate bathrooms and seeing if any
actually require
15 flushes as donald trump predicted
they would under joe biden
joe shalom says the more i hear about
donald trump the more i don't care for
him
i saw how you held your glasses you took
a drink of water oh yeah i just i just
drink water
oh okay here's the schedule house
managers get up to eight hours today
uh defense gets eight hours friday eight
hours saturday although rumors are that
they will not use the full time
then there will be questions witnesses
closing and vote
well into next week well into next week
um
that's what we are expecting um
senators say trial could rap as soon as
sunday i i believe that it's the defense
could wrap as soon as sunday
um and then you would still need i think
what four hours of questions from either
side
people asking where the podcast is the
podcast is on
itunes stitcher spotify
pandora google podcasts
where else really anywhere anywhere
uh okay other super chats coming in
indigo puzzles
with the top super chat of the day 50
bucks says pacman i love your work
download lopin link free puzzle app oh
so it's like a promo
all right is the gear store open i need
a coffee mug yes the youtube
gear store is open we are right now uh
selling gear only through youtube due to
coronavirus related shipping uh issues
we've had but the gear store and mugs
available
through youtube david do you think the
inevitable acquittal will foment the
split of the republican
party from the party of trump will we
see the patriot party emerge
i actually am planning a story for
tomorrow's podcast about this
where on the one hand we have um
trump saying he may start his own party
there's also
a hundred former republican officials
who are saying they don't like how pro
pro-trump the republican party is they
may quit
and create the principled conservative
party
there would be nothing better for the
left than the republican party
party fracturing into three the trump
people leave and follow trump
the so-called conservatives leave and
follow conservatives
and then i guess you just have kind of
some clowns left over let's listen to
what joe biden said i need a hearing lie
because i was going straight through
last night to a little after nine
but i watched some this morning i think
the senate has a
very important job to complete and i
think
my guess is some minds may have been
changed but i don't know
i actually love that joe biden barely
says
anything about the impeachment uh
he's not involved in it he's not in the
senate he wasn't part of
the impeachment in the house he's not
part of the trial
in the senate um he's been doing this
exactly right
just completely completely staying out
of it uh we
i did unfortunately have to ban hammer a
bunch of people during the first session
mostly on twitch there's a little
banning happening on youtube but
overwhelmingly people getting banned on
twitch people
showing up and uh who never participate
before
just dropping horrible messages we will
not hesitate to
use the bandhammer and if people want to
appeal the ban then we will adjudicate
those appeals
at uh at some future point in time no
big deal not a problem whatsoever
other super chats continuing to come in
ej says david thank you for getting me
interested in learning about media
literacy and
coffee you are a great human being i'm
actually looking
this is breaking news but i am looking
at maybe
a change to my
espresso machine and i'm looking at a
few different things i'm looking at
sep right now i have the breville
barista express
which has an in none of these are
sponsors by the way which has an
integrated grinder in it and i'm looking
at separating out
the grinder and the espresso machine and
maybe going to
a double boiler maybe go i may be going
to a rocket
machine there's just a lot going on from
the standpoint of coffee and i'm still
exploring it
the other thing by the way i'm not
joking but it's just kind of irrelevant
the one thing i do want to mention
because i know we have so many tech
people in the audience
i am looking at making a dramatic
upgrade to my
uh laptop from the standpoint
of being able to better stream
while not at the main studio and
i need you know the problem i have with
laptops is
i like a solid laptop with the number
pad
and like a nice keyboard i also want to
be able to do multiple monitors
i hate these super thick gaming laptops
where the fan it's like you're in a wind
tunnel i can't have that because i'm
streaming i can't have that picked up by
the mic
so in any case i'm looking at pc only
i'm not doing any apple stuff pc only
i would love a little bit of advice
about a a good
solid streaming laptop i would
appreciate that people can email me
through my website osculatingplane says
i upped my patreon
from seven dollars a month to a hundred
per year thank you very much
that's i think does that make it 833 a
month would a website membership be
better for the show it's all good for
the show
everything is good for the show ferret
queen says cicilline is beloved in rhode
island for good reason he's very good
he's very very good i see people asking
why is there going to be an acquittal
well there's going to be an acquittal
because there aren't 17 republicans who
are actually willing
to uh consider voting guilty voting to
convict
we just we know that uh okay
very good let's see what else we've got
i do want to make sure because we don't
get these breaks super often that i'm
catching everybody up on
everything um
oh come on it's got to be a joke this
entire
the coupon code is not working thing the
coupon code is working people are using
it
i think i'm not going to be able to
respond to that anymore because i think
people are just trolling me with it
quite frankly
um thanks to hack fuey
who just gifted a subscription as well
as shaunicus
chabo robot 503 phoenix beef goggles
and a whole bunch of other people
grabbing twitch subs
which i very much appreciate uh
looks like we are at uh where where were
we 1841
that's a plus five there just getting
through a lot of housekeeping stuff here
not a problem whatsoever
all right very good um and then
i did miss one member thank you and that
is dgg for
life has signed up dear god for a
membership at joinpackman.com
thanks to dgg for life for the new
membership
uh or gappy as they may also
be known um ben says check out james
hoffman for espresso machines absolutely
i i this may be an audacious statement i
believe
that uh james hoffman is the top coffee
youtuber top coffee youtuber i don't
know if there are folks who would
disagree with me on that
i can't think of anybody right now who
is doing better coffee related content
than james hoffman
nobody disagrees very good do uh jacob
says do you think the violent rhetoric
against landlords and stuff from people
on the left hurts us on an optics level
i i don't think it i mean listen there's
a debate to be had there but i don't
think there's enough of it to really be
making a
a huge impact one way or the other yes
there are some like mom and pop
landlords
yes there are some big corporate
landlords
i don't i don't think it's uh a big
issue i don't think it's raiding right
now
alex says laptop wise get a razor blade
stealth razor blade stealth
all right i've made a note of that i
will look into that
um i do want a 15 inch screen
some of these laptops with fifth with 13
inchers
do i look like i'm going to be working
with a 13-incher guys
not likely not likely what software do i
use for streaming streamlabs obs
i use streamlabs obs and i'm very very
happy with it i must say
no complaints whatsoever um
i do stream left-handed for people who
are asking yeah
left-handed thanks to barton breakfast
as well appreciate that um
people asking if we're missing things we
are missing nothing
we are missing nothing um
live is on the left the senate is in
recess until the bottom of the hour
uh okay could i somehow get a laptop for
streaming that also makes coffee
that's interesting that's actually very
interesting i wouldn't be against that
bobby says david highly recommend a
lilit bianca
dual boiler with flow control for value
beautiful machine niche
zero also a great grinder
blanca espresso what is the la lit
bianca look like
oh yeah this is this is similar to the
rocket that's a similar that's similar
yeah
no that's an interesting machine maddie
says easiest 100 zero vote ever
republicans better grow a spine
listen guys when i say that this is
going to an acquittal it's not because
i'm prejudging anything it's that
most republicans have already prejudged
and said they're going to vote to acquit
i know people get mad every time i say
it but it's just the reality
connor lazaro says i put a coupon in my
disk drive now it's stuck that sounds
like a problem
agent 47 says david is there a full
version of your show's intro i really
like it
i don't know the answer to that i'm not
sure yeah there must be somewhere
um
mocha pot some people recommending the
mocha pot yeah the mocha pot's not bad
it's a nice
nice little device thanks to krista
adams for signing up at joinedpakman.com
krista
you're a great american to quote sean
hannity even though i don't even know if
you are american
but i appreciate that um yeah people are
coming in and saying they doubt that
there would be enough votes for
conviction
but will some republican senators change
their minds yes i am expecting some
republican conviction votes
i think that it won't be 17 but i am
expecting some senate
votes from republicans to convict
and uh we will we will know soon
we will know very very soon sir man dude
guy says
i can the trump party trump teenagers
because
that what they've been proving how they
act like
i don't know what that means i
appreciate the super chat but i really
don't know
uh i don't i don't know what that means
i'm struggling with that
with that one the trump presidency
seemed like a polanski film
says search yeah i don't know that could
be interpreted
a number of different ways i don't know
exactly what way
uh you believe it was like a polanski
film
but uh yeah no i am not considering
i'm not considering any pod based
espresso machines no
i again as i've said i have a um i have
a breville barista express
and i'm considering an upgrade
considering an upgrade general anubis
says i recommend
a sega clevo laptop from
zodik pc solid manufacturer can be as
thin or beefy as needed
all right i i've never heard of so many
of these brands
i'm really out of the laptop laptop game
i basically just get a new dell
that's all i ever think of to do thanks
to alex civic
as well as lena killstrom
almost like kill stream lena killstrom
uh new members number 37 and 38 today
at joinpackman.com
why am i discriminating against
pod-based espresso machines
come on guys come on
i i know we can't i'm not going to delve
into that you all know i haven't been to
a fast food restaurant
in 18 years i consider pod
based coffee machines the equivalent of
a fast food restaurant all right
thank you when will the conviction vote
happen
i would say no earlier than sunday and
probably no later
than um wednesday
something like that david get a laptop
with a docking station the docking
station is great for multi-monitor
setups also you could use the laptop's
keyboard or a separate keyboard
yeah but now but then i've got a now i'm
bringing a keyboard a laptop a docking
station
now i'm bringing a whole bunch of stuff
around
is it a bad thing to demonize any
republican who votes against conviction
because they totally deserve it well i
don't know about demonize but
we should be able to say that their vote
was wrong
would i consider stephen wants to know
if i'd consider more engagement with
other online left creators
you are a great influence on them and
for the online left scene as a whole
well i appreciate that you know i'm
pretty full on in terms of a schedule
so i don't know how much more engagement
i can really do
but always glad to help build the
community
i call the trump party trump teenagers
says sir man dude guy
can trump still run for president if he
is in prison
uh don't know that's a that's a good
question you'd have to ask a lawyer
about that
bustanut inua says i highly recommend
breville products
yes i have a breville machine now and
it's it's it's a great machine
noogie has subscribed for seven months
and says love you packies
um appreciate that thank you very much
um leif westermark has sent a super chat
and i'm just struggling to see it
weird lenovo legion five or seven have
you tried roasting beans at home it's
great fun a friend of mine has a roaster
and we roasted like a quarter cup of
beans once
it was okay i mean he buys these
50 pound bags of green coffee beans and
then roasts them
a little more work than i'm willing to
do on a day to day basis but i did
participate once in a roasting
session elements of roasting took place
big thank you to tim gapinski tim just
signed up at joinedpakman.com and his
new number number 30
new member 39. we're standing by for the
start of
the next um couple of hour session
of the last day of the house managers
prosecution tomorrow the defense will
start
we don't know if it will be led uh
off again by a bruce castor or whether
they're going to skip directly to david
shone which
probably would be smarter based on what
we saw from david shone on monday
was really really ugly uh and did not do
trump any favors
interesting article from the washington
post and josh dossey about how
trump is basically miserable miserable
down in florida
watching what's going on
uh someone recommending that i do a mini
itx build here's the thing guys
i'm so i know that it's the cool thing
you're not nobody's legit unless they're
building their own laptop now
i just need to buy a laptop i just need
to buy a laptop so i'm sure that i can
get
a 15 better computer for 15 less money
if i build it
but i just need to buy a laptop that's
the way it works and i need a laptop
that will be
fully powerfully enabled for streaming
multiple elements
in the future dell xpx 15
is being recommended by mr rad
i'm not familiar with that one you know
the problem with a lot of dells
is in order to make them super thin
they have these tiny uncomfortable lap
laptop keyboards i need
like a strong comfortable laptop
keyboard
um a lot of lenovo recommendations which
sounds interesting
says i say this as a fan but i feel
you pretended not to know jimmy dore to
avoid having an opinion on the force to
vote
i never pretended not to know who jimmy
dore was that never happened
the first time i got a call about force
the vote i just hadn't heard about force
the vote
i never pretended to know to not know
who jimmy dore was this just never
happened
and this is the problem hamad people
start
repeating these false claims oh david
pretended not to know who jimmy dore is
never happened
what happened is the first time someone
called in about forced the vote
i hadn't heard about it that's it
then i heard about it dom says you
should have richard wolff on the show
soon i was just on his show not long ago
joshua davies
says i greatly appreciate the channel
it's been invaluable as i've been
expanding my political horizons
mitt romney is my uncle is that true but
your ideas have been convinced
convincing just left the republican
party yeah anybody wearing a suit in
their
youtube profile icon i believe
at some point was a republican i believe
that
james spielmaker says pacman are you
human i'm suspicious
are your calm demeanor and
even-handedness thanks for your voice
thanks james i think david says leave
the dock at home carry the laptop right
but no see i don't need the dock at home
there are some projects upcoming where i
may be broadcasting a little bit longer
term
from outside of my main studio that's
where i need
the more powerful streaming setup get a
little bit more light on here
there we go uh so i would need to bring
the
bring the dock david my computer savvy
friend helped me pick out an acer
and it's been good massive screen as
well says joshua
david have you listened to the podcast
it could happen here no i've never heard
of it
i should get a macbook pro with the m1
chip
looking for a pc my friends looking for
a pc
thanks for tj view as well as chill sd
and a giggle sniffer for signing up via
twitch
putting us at uh where does that put us
at
43. here is mitch mcconnell winding his
way back into the senate
i do want to say uh thank you to nick
finocchiaro
and ignotus assadouskas
for signing up at joinpakman.com putting
us at 45
appreciate that guys
uh is giggle sniffer some kind of inside
joke i'm not familiar with
maybe i should ask if i if i were to go
to a streamer for advice
on a laptop should i go to steven
kenneth destiny bennell ii
or should i go to hassan
who would be stronger on this issue
okay most people seem to say neither
okay that the the consensus is neither
hoopla cake may says
asus laptops have done me wonders
what features am i looking for i'm
looking for a 15-inch screen the ability
to plug in multiple monitors
the ability for it to handle uh running
all sorts of different things at once
as well as a comfortable keyboard
it's a shame republicans had to be put
in danger to decide trump was a tiny bit
bad for the country well what's crazy is
many of them were put in danger
and still haven't decided trump is bad
for the country
why are tyt against means testing i have
no idea i i don't watch other shows like
mine
a girl once dumped me for not having
enough zest for life says daniel
so i started collecting orange peel
shavings
that that is a dad pun if i've ever
heard one
t kitlitz says the coupon code should be
impeached completely unconstitutional
i don't disagree i don't disagree
am i fully vaccinated i am not i am
partially vaccinated
will be fully vaccinated by let me think
i guess march 5th
calls pc asked for andrew elias tell him
i
sent you anybody know about this exotic
pc stuff
custom gaming computers laptops and
notebooks is that a solid brand
i've never heard of it
exotic
overpriced ooh
that's brutal it's pronounced exotic
i prefer saying exotic i don't know why
dell precision would work
lg gram all the things you want and a
touch screen killer battery life
see this is by it's so difficult because
everybody has
very black white perspectives on uh
laptops get an aurora 7 laptop with
seven
screens ryan says get an asus
zephyrus duo extra screen
built into the deck this will help you
that's interesting i've never heard of
that
that's five grand okay i mean how long
would that last me
is it asus or asus
my budget is whatever it needs to be i
mean this is a work element
it's a work element
um danny thompson
sends the top super chat of the day at
106
21 and says unless mitch wants trump out
for good
and assembles a group of republicans
large enough there will be no
conviction of course yeah danny there's
not going to be a conviction
he is not making any media statements
right now unlike the first impeachment
so i am as hopeful as i can be smash
like and subscribe and if you can match
my super chat wow danny thompson with a
shot across
the bow at other viewers asking for a
matched
super chat david did you know 10 plus 10
and 11 plus 11 equals the same thing
no i did not no i did not
instead of going through the trial which
we all know the results says mart why
can't the senate and congress focus on
the relief
package my understanding is that they
can they have until noon each day to do
other business
use stints built he builds laptops
builds for streamers yeah i should get a
desktop computer and drag it around with
me
no in all seriousness if people really
have suggestions
on laptop stuff email me through my
website
oh my god i have one two three four
five six seven emails about it including
people
offering to do consultations for me wow
okay maybe don't email me anymore
i've already gotten a bunch of emails do
i prefer streaming on another platform
no i'm happy with the platform i have
the platform i have is working fine for
me
cnet reviews you want the best macbook
pro alternative category
docs are dead use usbc
do people agree with that no more docs i
can get everything i need with a usbc
um what do you plug in
do you plug in a hub to usbc and then
plug in whatever monitors you need is
that the gist
rather than a dock
usb monitor lightning port okay that's
fair yeah see this is good i'm learning
about it
thanks to meet roomba for three months
on twitch
also appreciate the gift from canned
caviar cgj
has also signed up tj vue as well
lots of great people yeah i'll i'll go
through all those emails about laptops
later
i mean it's like you know it's hard to
buy a laptop while streaming
how on earth did i get a vaccine if i'm
young and not working in healthcare
uh so there are unfortunately lots of
places that are ending up with
uh unused doses and i was
fortunate enough to know someone who is
running the vaccine program
at a at a location and said i keep a
list i have a commitment to zero
wastage we get cancellations we get
different things
um around 8 pm i will know if i have a
few leftovers
if you want one i will um put you on the
list we don't want to waste a single one
and that's that's uh that's what
happened
all right thank you very much more
people telling me about a laptop with
seven screens
sinful solutions matching a super chat
not with 106 21 but 16 21
still appreciate that
uh i know i'm falling behind and i
forgot to thank some people
thanks to brittany miller for signing up
at joinedpakman.com thanks brittany
very much appreciate that britney using
the coupon code
and it worked perfectly absolutely
perfectly
how long do we expect this to go today a
common question for many people
probably five
ish more hours up to five-ish more hours
i mean
i'm hoping they don't use all of their
time they've made their case
um i'm hoping they they just rap soon
it's time it's time
who is on oh we actually had a great
great guest i recorded an interview
earlier today
this is on today's podcast going live in
45 minutes i interviewed michael kinch
today
who wrote a really great book about the
history of uh vaccines
we talked about how you disabuse people
of anti-vaxx
perspectives what herd immunity
threshold is likely to be
with the current new variants um big
vaccine
sort of uh it's almost like a vaccine
summit that we had on today's podcast
okay
yeah i agree i agree with people uh who
are saying that
some of some of the um presentation
is is getting repetitive uh you know
there's this
i think it's very clear that the house
impeachment managers know
they need to make a comprehensive case
to give the impression that there's so
much evidence against trump and of
course
there is but this creates kind of a race
to the bottom
where it's like okay well let's do let's
do six hours let's do eight hours let's
do 10 hours obviously this could be done
in less time
obviously it could be done in less time
nobody ever said that these things
happen as efficiently as they could
there's no there's no question about
that
shannon says what do you think of
fidelity i have a robo advisor that buys
fidelity funds
i am not going to comment on any company
uh as far as that goes i don't know
anything about fidelity as i've said
before
uh i am mostly invested in
ultra low cost index funds total stock
market index fund total international
stock total bond fund
where you're paying five or 10 basis
points that's
it anything beyond that i don't know
anything about
if you're getting if you know if you're
charged getting charged uh
three percent or something like that or
even 50 basis points it's just too much
someone sent a 200 super chat i'm being
told
let's see unable to find it oh no here
it is oh my goodness
hoopla cake mace oh my god thank you
hoopla cake mace
sent a 200 canadian dollar super chat
and says matched the super chat put this
to the new computer buddy thank you
thanks hoopla
very much appreciate that i apologize i
didn't see that
but now i did that is strong that's
really really strong
um mr 337 says get a thin
business production laptop and purchase
an external dedicated
gpu for monitors and streaming you can
take the laptop for production tasks and
there will be no heat or noise
yeah see this is what i need advice on
like what's actually most efficient
is it getting walking around with a dock
and a laptop
or a laptop and an external gpu
or some kind of hub for usb who the hell
knows
who the hell knows at this point it's
very difficult to know
ted cruz was tweeting about breast milk
during the trial
it was utter insanity that can't be true
i can't imagine that that's true
seems hard to imagine
talk to destiny about the best laptop
build yeah i just i just don't know
i don't know what he knows about laptops
thanks to julian pettis
for signing up at joinpackman.com
putting us at 50
50 today appreciate that
we are standing by they are in recess
until 15 minutes ago
and not yet back ah here we go they are
back
we'll continue as well live coverage on
c-span 2.
and once they resume i'll be back with
everybody very soon
let's see what the path forward is here
thank you mr president mr castro will
now return to address
the harm visited upon america's national
security
by these events in the damage to our
international reputation
oh a lot of craziness going on
all right we'll be back with you soon
my colleagues discussed with you the
many harms to our nation
as a result of president trump's conduct
now i'd like to spend to spend some time
talking about the harm to our national
security
and our standing in the world on january
6
when president trump incited a mob to
march to the capitol
he led them to a building that houses
some of our nation's most sensitive
information and consider
who was part of that mob some of the
individuals
were on the fbi watch list the past
behavior
of some individuals led here by
president trump so
alarmed investigators that their names
have been added
to the national terrorist screening
database and at least one of the
insurrectionists
may have intended to steal information
and give it
to a foreign adversary
according to charging documents riley
williams
allegedly helped steal a laptop from
speaker pelosi's office
to quote send the computer device to a
friend in russia
who then plan to sell the device to svr
russia's foreign intelligence service
while we can't be certain if or how many
foreign spies
infiltrated the crowd or at least
coordinated with those who did
we can be sure that any enemy who wanted
access to our secrets
would have wanted to be part of that mob
inside
these halls and the point is this
many of the insurrectionists that
president trump incited to invade this
chamber
were dangerous people on the fbi watch
list
violent extremists white supremacists
and these insurrectionists incited by
president trump
threatened our national security
stealing laptops again from speaker
pelosi's office
taking documents from leader mcconnell's
desk
snapping photographs as you saw in the
videos earlier
in sensitive areas ransacking your
offices
rifling through your desks the president
of the united states
the commander-in-chief knew the risk
of anyone breaching the capital he swore
an oath
to preserve protect and defend this
country
and yet he incited them here
to break into the capitol
senators as you all know
we have spent trillions of dollars
building the strongest military in the
world
and billions of dollars on the most
sophisticated
weaponry on the planet to
prevent the kind of attack that occurred
at this capitol on january 6th
and here's what the insurrectionist
incited by president trump
did
oh my god we did the [ __ ] we took this
[ __ ]
in many ways this room is sacred
and so are the traditions that it
represents
they've been carried on for centuries
congress has declared war 11 times
on this floor including
entering world war ii and congress
passed the civil rights act
and expanded the right to vote to ensure
that no matter your race
or your gender you have a voice in our
nation
this floor is where history has been
made
and now our intelligence agencies and
law enforcement agencies
have the burden to figure out exactly
what was stolen
taken ransacked and compromised
as acting u.s attorney michael sherwin
explained quote
materials were stolen and we have to
identify
what was done mitigate that and it could
have potential
national security equities
these investigations are necessary now
because of the actions
of president trump and it wasn't just
the people that he led here
the intelligence agencies have to look
into
it's also what they took and what they
gathered
and it was the very fact that this
building was so much sensitive
information
and some classified information that
this capital
was breached and think about it
every foreign adversary considering
attacking this building
got to watch a dress rehearsal and they
saw
that this capital could be overtaken
as elizabeth newman a former trump
administration
official stated quote
you have terrorists who would love to
destroy the capital
they just saw how easy it was to
penetrate
we just exposed a huge vulnerability
and it's not just the capital this
attack has implications
for all government buildings and senator
rubio
made this point well
if you're a terrorist right now you're
sitting out there watching this you're
saying to yourself hey it's not that
hard to get into the capitol maybe
that's not hard to get into the white
house or the supreme court building or
somewhere else
our government our intelligence agencies
and our law enforcement have implemented
additional safety measures since the
attack on january 6th
but while we secure this physical space
what message will we send
the rest of the world
we already know that we already know
that the message our adversaries took
from january 6 this is how some of them
responded
after the attack
quote for america's adversaries there
was no greater proof of the valuability
of western democracy than the site of
the u.s
capitol shrouded in smoke and besieged
by a mob whipped up by their unwillingly
outgoing president
to make matters worse our adversaries
are even using the events
of january 6 not only to denigrate
america
but to justify their own anti-democratic
behavior
calling america hypocritical
here's what the chinese government is
saying
the spokesperson for china's ministry of
foreign affairs
said the capital riot should spark quote
deep reflection
among u.s lawmakers regarding how they
discuss the pro-democracy movement
in hong kong suggesting that the u.s
is hypocritical in denouncing beijing's
crackdown in the city
while it struggles with its own unrest
at home
in the global times an outlet affiliated
with the chinese communist party
even tweeted a series of side by side
photos
of two events the siege of the u.s
capitol and a july 2019 incident
in which pro-democracy protesters in
hong kong broke into the city's
legislative council building
think about that president trump
gave the chinese government an opening
to create a false equivalency between
hong kongers protesting for democracy
and violent insurrectionists trying to
overthrow it
as representative gallagher described in
real time
and we don't think other countries
around the world are watching this
happen right now
we don't think the chinese communist
party is sitting back and laughing
and we're deluding ourselves so call it
off mr president
we need you to call this off
russia has also seized on this violent
attack against our government
decrying that democracy is quote
over the chairman
of the russian upper house of
parliament's international affairs
committee
said quote the celebration of democracy
is
over this is alas actually the bottom
i say this without a hint of gloating
america is no longer charting the course
and therefore
has lost all its rights to set it
and especially to impose it on others
they're using president trump's
incitement
of an insurrection to declare
that democracy is over
in iran the supreme leader is using
president trump's incitement of
insurrection
to mock america he said of the situation
in the united states
quote this is their democracy and human
rights
this is their election scandal these are
their values
these values are being mocked by the
whole world
even their friends are laughing at them
these statements are serious
and pervasive and according
to a joint threat assessment bulletin
from the department of homeland security
the fbi and eight other law enforcement
entities
quote since the incident at the u.s
capitol on january 6
russian iranian and chinese influence
actors have seized the opportunity
to amplify narratives in furtherance of
their policy interests
amid the presidential transition
we cannot let them use what happened on
january 6
to define us who we are
and what we stand for
we get to define ourselves by how we
respond
to the attack of january 6th
and some might be tempted to say and
point out
that our adversaries are always going to
be critical of the united states
but following the insurrection on
january 6
even our allies are speaking up
canadian prime minister justin trudeau
said quote
what we witnessed was an assault on
democracy by violent rioters
incited by the current president and
other politicians
as shocking deeply disturbing
and frankly saddening as that event
remains we have also seen this week
the democracy is resilient in america
our closest ally
and neighbor the george the
german foreign minister said quote
this closing of ranks begins with
holding those accountable
who are responsible for such escalations
that includes the violent writers and it
also includes
their instigators
the world is watching and wondering
whether we are who we say we are
because when our other countries have
known chaos
our constitution has helped keep order
in america
this is why we have a constitution
we must stand up for the rule of law
because the rule of law
doesn't just stand up by itself
after the insurrection my colleagues on
the house foreign affairs committee
the chairman and the ranking member
issued a bipartisan statement
that said quote america has always been
a beacon of freedom to the world
proof that free and fair elections are
achievable
and the democracy works but what
happened at the capitol today
has scarred our reputation and has
damaged
our standing in the world today's
violence
an inevitable result when leaders in
positions of power
misled the public will certainly empower
dictators
and damage struggling democracies
and that's true for generations the
united states has been a north star in
the world
for freedom democracy and human rights
because america is not only a nation
for many it's also an idea
it's the light that gives hope to people
struggling for democracy
in autocratic regimes the light that
inspires people
fighting across the world for
fundamental human rights
and the light that inspires us to
believe in something
larger than ourselves this trial
is an opportunity to respond and to send
a message
back to the world
i say this as somebody who loves my
country
our country just as all of you do
is a lot of courage in this room
a lot of courage that has been
demonstrated in the lives
of the people in this room
some folks have stood up for the civil
rights of fellow americans
and risked their careers and their
reputations
their livelihoods and their safety
standing up for civil rights
many members of congress have risked
their lives in service
to our country in uniform
fighting in the jungles of vietnam
patrolling the mountains of afghanistan
you served our country because you were
willing to sacrifice
to defend our nation as we know it
and as the world knows it
and although most of you have traded in
your uniform
for public service
your country needs you one more time
the world watched president trump tell
his big lie
the world watched his supporters come to
washington
at his invitation and the world watched
as he told his supporters to march here
to the capitol
and president trump our
commander-in-chief at the time
failed to take any action to defend us
as he utterly failed in his duty
to preserve protect and defend
and now the world is watching us
wondering whether our constitutional
republic
is going to respond the way it should
the way it's supposed to whether the
rule of law
will prevail over mob rule
because the answer to that question
has consequences far beyond our own
borders
think of the consequences to our
diplomats and negotiators as they sit at
tables around the world
to enforce our agenda on trade
the economy and human rights
to fail to convict a president of the
united states
who incited a deadly insurrection who
acted in concert
with a violent mob who interfered with
the certification
of the electoral college votes who
abdicated his duty as commander-in-chief
would be to forfeit the power of our
example as a north star
on freedom democracy human rights
and most of all on the rule of
law and to convict donald trump
would mean that america stands
for the rule of law no matter who
violates it
let us show the world that january 6th
was not america and let us remind the
world
that we are truly their north star
representative representative august and
i will now address
the first amendment argument that's
being offered
by president trump's lawyers to try to
excuse his incitement to this
insurrection and mr new goose will begin
mr president distinguished senators good
afternoon
you have heard over the course of last
several days
overwhelming evidence that president
trump incited an insurrection
but as lead manager raskin mentioned as
as we prepare to close
we'd be remiss if we didn't just briefly
address apparently the principal defense
that
the president will offer to excuse
his conduct and that is this notion that
he can't be held accountable for what
happened
on january 6th because his actions are
somehow protected by the first amendment
now let's stop a moment
and try to really understand the
argument
that they are making according to
president trump
everything he did everything
we showed you that he did
was perfectly okay for him to do
and for a future president to do again
and the constitution apparently in their
view
forbids you from doing anything
to stop it
that can't be right it can't be
and it isn't right
their argument is meant as a distraction
they are concerned not with the facts
that actually occurred
the facts that we've proven but with an
alternative
set of facts where president trump did
nothing but
deliver a controversial speech at a
rally
of course that's not what we've charged
in the article of impeachment
and it's not what happened you will hear
from my colleague lead manager raskin
the many
myriad reasons why this argument that
they make
is wrong on the law completely
not just around the edges they make
major fundamental mistakes of
constitutional law the kind
that lead manager raskin tells me
wouldn't cut it
in his first year law course which of
course
he certainly would know since he has
taught this subject for
decades
and that explains why so many
lawyers who've dedicated their lives
to protecting free speech including many
of the nation's
most prominent conservative free speech
lawyers
have described president trump's first
amendment claims
as quote legally frivolous
another quote from a recent letter
prominent
free speech lawyers that quote the first
amendment is no
bar to the senate convicting former
president trump
and disqualifying him from holding
future office
their argument is wrong on the facts
wrong on the law and would flip the
constitution
upside down let's start
with the facts because as you'll see
his free speech claim depends on an
account of what he did
of why we're here that has no basis
in the evidence to hear his lawyers tell
it
he was just some guy at a rally
unpopular opinions they would have you
believe
that this whole impeachment is because
he said things that one may
disagree with really
and make no mistake they will do
anything
to avoid talking about the facts of
this case that i can assure you
instead we expect they will talk about a
lot of other speeches
including some given by democratic
officials and they will insist with
indignation that the first amendment
protects
all of this is as though it were exactly
the same
we trust you to know the difference
because you've seen the evidence that
we've seen
you've seen as we've proven over the
last three days
that his arguments completely
misdescribe the
reality of what happened on january 6th
they leave out everything that matters
about why we're here
and what he did because president trump
wasn't just some guy with political
opinions
who showed up at a rally on january 6
and delivered controversial remarks
he was the president of the united
states
and he had spent months months
using the unique power of that office
of his bully pulpit to spread that big
lie
that the election had been stolen to
convince
his followers to stop the steal to
assemble them
just blocks away from here on january
six
at the very moment that we were meeting
to count
the electoral vote college votes where
he knew where it had been
widely reported that they were primed
and eager
and ready for violence at his signal
and then standing in the middle
of that explosive situation
in that powder keg that he had created
over the course of months before a crowd
filled with people that were poised for
violence
at his signal he struck a match
and he aimed it straight at this
building
at us you've seen
all that evidence there's no denying it
that's why the house impeached him
that's why he's on trial
no president no matter their politics
or the politics of their followers
conservative
liberal or anything else no president
can do what president trump did
because this isn't about politics it's
about
his refusal to accept the outcome of the
election and
his decision to incite an insurrection
and there's no serious argument
that the first amendment protects that
and it would be extraordinarily
dangerous for the united states
senate to conclude otherwise
to tell future presidents
that they can do exactly what president
trump did and get away with it
to set the precedent that this is an
acceptable
now a constitutionally protected way
to respond to losing an election
and you'll notice something certainly
something lead manager asking and i
noticed which is that
by all accounts doesn't appear that
president trump's lawyers
disagree i mean they don't insist that
if the facts
we've charged the facts that we have
proven
the facts supported by overwhelming
evidence
are true as of course you now know
they are that there's nothing you can do
they're not arguing that it's okay for a
person to
incite a mob to violence at least i
don't think they're arguing that
instead what they are doing is offering
a radically different version
of what happened that day totally
inconsistent
with the evidence and then they insist
that if that
fictional version of events if that
alternate reality were true
well then he may be protected by the
first amendment that's their argument
that you are here to adjudicate
real evidence real facts
not hypothetical ones and for that
reason
alone you should reject
their argument because it has been
advanced to defend
a situation that bears no resemblance to
the actual facts
of this case with that i want to turn it
over to my colleague lee manager raskin
to address
the many legal flaws as i mentioned in
president trump's position
so mr nagoos just explained why
president trump's
um last-ditch first amendment argument's
got nothing to do with the actual facts
of the case
uh he's been impeached for inciting
violent insurrection
against the government incitement to
violent insurrection is not protected
by free speech there is no first
amendment
defense to impeachment for high crimes
and misdemeanors
the idea itself is absurd and
the whole first amendment smoke screen
is a completely irrelevant distraction
from the standard of high crimes and
misdemeanors governing a president
who has violated his oath of office yet
president trump
we know has a good way of treating up as
down and wrong is right
he tried to pull off the biggest
election fraud in american history
by overturning the results of the 2020
election even as he insisted
that his own fraud was in fact an effort
to stop the steel to stop a fraud
a vast concer conspiracy that he blamed
on
local and state officials of both
political parties the media
election officials the judiciary federal
state
members of congress many others anybody
who wouldn't go along with him
was part of the conspiracy
he violated his own oath of office by
inciting mob violence to prevent
congress
from counting the electoral college
votes as we're assigned to do by the
12th amendment and electoral account act
even as he attacked vice president pence
at a rally
for violating his oath of office
and going along with an egregious
assault on democracy
now he argues that the congress is
violating
his free speech rights when it was
donald trump who incited an
insurrectionist attack against us
that halted speech and debate on the
floor of the house and the senate
during the peaceful transfer of power
and that imperiled
the very constitutional order that
protects freedom of speech in the first
place
along with all of our other fundamental
rights
as a matter of law it's a matter of
logic
president trump's brazen intent to
invoke the first amendment now
won't hold up in any way
the basic flaw of course is that it
completely ignores the fact that
he was president of the united states a
public official
he swears an oath as president that
nobody else wears
in exchange he's given greater powers
than anybody else in the entire country
maybe on earth he or she promises to
preserve
protect and defend the constitution of
the united states
and our government institutions and our
people
and as we all know the power we entrust
to people
in public office and government office
especially our presidents
comes with special obligations to uphold
the laws and the integrity of our
republic
and we all swear that of now what if a
president
publicly say a president publicly on a
daily basis advocated
replacing the constitution with a
totalitarian form of government
and urged states to secede from the
union and swore an
oath of loyalty to a foreign leader or
foreign government
well as a private citizen you couldn't
do anything about people
using those words to advocate
totalitarianism
to advocate secession from the union to
swear an
oath of personal loyalty to a foreign
leader or foreign government or country
you couldn't
that's totally protected if you tried to
prosecute somebody for that
as a prosecutor you would lose but it is
simply
inconceivable unthinkable
that a president could do any of these
things
get up and swear an oath to foreign
governments or leaders to advocate
totalitarianism advocate secession and
not be impeached for it
it's just unthinkable that that could
happen would that violate their first
amendment rights
the opposite view pressed here by
president trump's council would leave
the nation powerless to respond to a
president who uses the unmatched
power privilege and prestige of his or
her office
the famous bully pulpit in ways that
risk
the ruin of the republic all for his or
her own ambition
and corruption and lust for power
everyone should be clear there's nothing
remotely exotic about what we're saying
it should be common sense to everybody
common sense about this understanding of
the first amendment
as it applies to public servants cops
firefighters teachers everybody across
the land
my daughter who i mentioned earlier in
trial she's a teacher in a public school
the courts have said teachers teach but
if they go off script and they start
advocating totalitarianism
treason or what have you they're not
living up
to the duties of their office as teacher
they can be fired everybody knows that
and it happens all the time by the way
including to cops and firefighters and
people on the front lines happens all
the time
in fact it happened countless times to
people fired
by president trump for their statements
or
ideas about things including on election
fraud
not long ago there are people in the
government
who lost their jobs because the
president didn't like what they said
or what they wrote now
as i mentioned yesterday and i can't
help but repeat it justice scalia got it
exactly right on this he
he wrote on these cases about how the
first amendment affects
people who take on a public office who
take on public
employment and he summed it up like this
he said
you can't ride with the cops but root
for the robbers
you can't ride with the cops but root
for the robbers that's what justice
scalia said
and when it comes to the peaceful
transfer of power to the rule of law
to respecting election outcomes our
president
whoever he or she is must
choose the side of the constitution
must and not the side of the
insurrection
or the coup or anybody who's coming
against us
and if he or she chooses the wrong side
i'm sorry
there's nothing in the first amendment
or anywhere else in the constitution
they can excuse your betrayal of your
oath of office
it's not a free speech question
but there's more let's play make believe
and pretend that president trump were
just a run-of-the-mill private citizen
as my colleague mr nagoo said
just another guy at the rally who's just
expressing a deeply unpopular opinion
because we shouldn't overlook the fact
that
while there were thousands of people in
that violent mob they represent a
tiny tiny tiny part of less than one
percent
of the population and the vast majority
of the american people
reject the kind of seditious mob
violence
that we saw on january 6th
but let's say that he was another guy
in the crowd that day
it is a bedrock principle that nobody
nobody can incite a riot first amendment
doesn't protect it
key case brandenburg versus ohio there's
no
first amendment protection for speech
directed to inciting or producing
imminent lawless action
and likely to produce such action and
for all the reasons you've heard
based on the voluminous comprehensive
totally unrefuted and we think
irrefutable but we're eager to hear our
colleagues
based on all the evidence you've heard
and for all the reasons you've heard
that definition of proscribable speech
fits president trump's conduct perfectly
this is a classic case
of incitement and you have to take my
word for it
the 144 free speech lawyers mr nagoos
mentioned
who include many of the nation's most
dedicated
most uncompromising free speech
advocates
unlike mr trump of course but these
people agree
that there is a powerful case for
conviction
under the brandenburg standard even if
the president of the united states
were just to be treated like some guy in
the crowd and they add
the first amendment is no defense to the
article of impeachment
leveled against the former president
and i mentioned the brandenburg standard
not because it applies here of course it
doesn't since this is
an impeachment it's not a criminal trial
and there's no risk of jail time let's
be clear about that
the president doesn't go to jail for one
week one day one hour or one
minute based on impeachment and
conviction
and disqualification from further office
rather i mention it to emphasize that
absolutely nobody in america
would be protected by the first
amendment if they did all the things
that donald trump
did nobody made donald trump run for
president and swear an oath
to preserve protect and defend the
constitution on january 20
2017 but when he did by virtue of
swearing that oath and
entering this high office he took upon
himself a duty
to affirmally take care that our laws
would be faithfully executed under his
leadership
all of the laws the laws against
federal destruction of property all of
the laws
we expected him in everything he said in
everything he did to protect and
preserve and defend
our constitutional system including the
separation of powers
but instead he betrayed us and as
representative cheney said
it was the greatest betrayal of a
presidential
oath in the history of the united states
of america
the greatest mentioning a
quoting a republican on that is slick
president trump is not even close to the
proverbial
citizen who falsely shouts fire in a
crowded theater
he is like the now proverbial municipal
fire chief who incites a mob
to go set the theater on fire and not
only refuses to put out the fire
but encourages the mob to keep going
as the blaze spreads we
would hold that fire chief accountable
we would forbid him from that job
ever again and that's exactly what must
happen here
there are hundreds of millions of
citizens who can be president
donald trump has disqualified himself
and you must disqualify him too
just like the fire chief who sends the
mob
president trump perverted his office by
attacking
the very constitution he was sworn to
uphold
in fact that's one reason why this free
speech rhetoric at this trial
is so insidious his conduct represented
the most
devastating and dangerous assault by a
government official
on our constitution including the first
amendment
in living memory we wouldn't have free
speech
or any other rights if we didn't have
the rule of law
peaceful transfer of power and a
democracy
where the outcome of the election is
accepted
by the candidate who lost
we had it all the way up until 2020
and the central purposes of the first
amendment are
democratic self-government and civic
truth-seeking two purposes
that president trump sought to undermine
not advance
in the course of his conduct as we have
definitively
demonstrated this trial the violence he
incited threatened
all of our freedoms it threatened a very
constitutional order
that protects free speech due process
religious free exercise
the right to vote equal protection and
the many other fundamental rights that
we all
treasure and cherish as citizens of the
united states
the first amendment does not create some
superpower
immunity from impeachment for a
president who attacks the constitution
in word indeed while rejecting the
outcome of an election
he happened to lose if anything
president trump's conduct was an assault
on the first amendment and equal
production rights that
millions of americans exercised when
they voted last year
often under extraordinarily difficult
and arduous circumstances
remember the first amendment protects
the right of the people to speak about
the great issues of our day
to debate during elections and then to
participate in politics by selecting
the people who will be our leaders and
remember in american democracy
those of us who aspire and attain the
public office are
nothing but the servants of the people
nothing not the masters of the people
we have no kings here we have no czars
here the people govern president ford
said the people
most important words of the constitution
are the first three we the people
but all this
all this means little if a president who
dislikes the election results
can incite violence to try to replace
and usurp the will of the people
as expressed in the states ignore the
judicial branch of government
and then run over the legislative branch
of government
with a mob president trump's high crimes
and misdemeanors
sought to nullify the political rights
and sovereignty of the american people
our right as a people to deliberate to
form opinions
to persuade each other to vote and then
to decide who our president will be
the sovereignty of the people that's an
attack on the first amendment i would
say
in addition president trump's actions
were a direct attack on our own freedom
of speech here in the capitol members of
congress are sent here
to speak for their constituents
that's why we have our own little mini
free speech clause the speech and debate
clause
that's literally our job we come here
and represent the views of our people
the attack that president trump incited
forced members of congress to stop
speaking and to literally flee for our
lives and the lives
of our staffs and our families the man
whose statements and actions halted
speech in congress
speech related to the peaceful transfer
of power has no
right no right to claim that free speech
principles
prevent this body from exercising its
constitutional power
is offense against us
you know voltaire said famously
and our founders knew it i may disagree
with everything you say
but i will defend with my life your
right to say it president trump says
because i disagree with everything you
say i will overturn your popular
election
and incite insurrection against the
government
and we might take a moment to consider
another voltaire insight
which a high school teacher of mine told
me when a student asked when was the
beginning of the enlightenment
and she said i think it was when
voltaire said anyone who can make you
believe absurdities
can make you commit atrocities
there's no merit whatsoever to any of
the free speech rhetoric the empty free
speech rhetoric you may hear from
president trump's lawyers
he attacked the first amendment he
attacked the constitution he betrayed
his oath of office
presidents don't have any right to do
that it's forbidden
so that our republic may survive the
people are far more important
than that the precedent he asked you to
create which would allow
any future president to do precisely
what he did is self-evidently
dangerous and so there can be no doubt
none at all
the president lacks any first amendment
excuse or
defense or immunity he incited
a violent insurrection against our
government
he must be convicted
wow
and now i'm going to call up a
representative dean
who will explain why contrary to the
president's claims the house provided
him
with all the process that was due to him
in this impeachment process
oh i'm sorry that mr liu is going to do
that
we will now hear from congressman ted
lieu
all right thank you for your time and
your attention
we all heard president trump's attorneys
on tuesday
and as part of president trump's efforts
to avoid talking about his own conduct
to avoid talking about anything related
to his constitutional crime
we expect that president trump will
raise
process objections his due process
claims are without merit under the
constitution
the house has quote the sole power
of impeachment that provision confirms
that the house functions as a grand jury
or a prosecutor
the house decides whether to bring
charges
now in other impeachment cases the house
has provided certain
deliberative and procedural privileges
to
the person being impeached but those are
exactly that
privileges they are discretionary
the house has the power to decide its
own rules
how it wants to pass the article of
impeachment
and in this case the house debated the
article of impeachment
and passed it on a bipartisan vote
i'm a former prosecutor i just want to
add
that i've had the opportunity to decide
whether to bring charges
and when you see a crime committed in
plain view
prosecutors don't have to spend months
investigating before they bring
charges i note that in this case in fact
hundreds of people have been arrested
and charged by prosecutors
for the violence on january 6.
there is no reason for the house to wait
to impeach
the man at the very top that incited
the violence i also like to emphasize
that the house had good
reason to move quickly this was an
exigent
circumstance this was not a case where
there was
hidden conduct or some conspiracy that
required months and maybe years of
investigation
this case does not raise very
complicated legal
issues the gravity of the president's
conduct demanded the clearest
of responses from the legislature
particularly given
that the president was still in office
at the time the house
approved this article and rumors of
further violence
echoed around the country they still do
there must be absolutely no doubt that
congress will act decisively against a
president
than cites violence against us
that is why the house moved quickly here
and president trump who created that
emergency
cannot be heard to complain that the
house impeached him too quickly for the
emergency
he caused another point on the due
process question
earlier in this trial president trump's
attorney
suggested that the house somehow
deliberately delay the transmission
of this article of impeachment that is
simply not
accurate
when the house adopted this article of
impeachment on a bipartisan vote
we were ready to begin trial
but the senate was not in session at the
time
and when we inquired as to our options
senate officials told us clearly and in
no
uncertain terms that the clerk of the
house
attempted to deliver the article of
impeachment to the secretary of the
senate before
the senate reconvened that the clerk of
the house
would have been turned back at the door
that's why the trial did not begin then
it's another reason why the president's
objections of due process
are meritless and finally
let me just conclude that you
all are going to see and have seen a
full presentation of evidence
by the house and you're going to hear a
full presentation
by their presence attorneys you're going
to be able to ask questions
the senate has the so power to try all
impeachments president trump is
receiving
any and all process that he is due
right here in this chamber
there is congressman ted lew jamie
raskin is back
mr president senators in just a moment
uh my colleague mr new goose will return
to show that we've established with
overwhelming evidence that president
trump
engaged in high crimes and misdemeanors
before mr
goose comes up though i'd like to
emphasize what should be an
uncontroversial point
but is really key to understand if we
have proven to you the conduct that
we've alleged in this article
then president trump has indeed
committed a high crime and misdemeanor
under the constitution
of insurrection under these
circumstances is undoubtedly in the
words of george mason from the
constitutional convention
a great and dangerous offense
against the republic indeed it is hard
to think
of a greater or more dangerous offense
against the republic than this one
so to be very precise about this
i hope we all can agree today
that if a president does incite
a violent insurrection against the
government
he can be impeached for it i hope we
all can agree that that is a
constitutional crime
another key point while president
trump's lawyers may be arguing otherwise
the question here is not
whether president trump committed a
crime under the
federal code or d.c law or the law of
any state
impeachment does not result in criminal
penalties
as we keep emphasizing no one spends a
day in jail
there are not even criminal or civil
fines centuries of history
not to mention the constitutional text
structure
and original intent and understanding
all confirm
the teaching of james wilson another
framer who wrote that impeachments and
offenses
come not within the sphere of ordinary
jurisprudence simply put
impeachment was created for a purpose
separate and distinct
from criminal punishment it was created
to prevent
and deter elected officials
it's crazy when you have to continually
remind republicans why it's okay to have
this trial
defenses against our republic
that's a constitutional crime and
senators
what greater offense could one commit
than to incite a
violent surrection insurrection at our
seat of government
during the peaceful transfer of power in
circumstances where violence is
foreseeable where a crowd
is poised for violence to provoke a mob
of thousands to attack us
with weapons and sticks and poles to
bludgeon
and beat our law enforcement officers
and to
deface these sacred walls and to trash
the place
and to do so while seeking to stop us
from fulfilling our own oaths
our own duties to uphold the
constitution by counting the votes
from our free and fair elections and
then to sit back
and watch in delight as insurrectionists
attack us violating a sacred oath and
engaging in a profound
dereliction and desertion of duty
how can we assure that our
commander-in-chief will protect preserve
and defend us in our constitution
if we don't hold a president accountable
in a circumstance like this
what is impeachable conduct if not this
i challenge you all to think about it if
you think this is not impeachable
what is what would be
if president trump's lawyers endorse his
breathtaking assertion reminds me of the
great bill walton who often said during
nba basketball games if that is not a
foul
do fouls even exist in the game then any
president
could incite and provoke insurrectionary
violence
against us again if you don't find this
a high crime and misdemeanor today you
have set
a new terrible standard for presidential
misconduct in the united states of
america the only real question here is
the factual one
did we prove that donald trump while
president of the united states incited a
violent insurrection against the
government
incitement of course is an inherently
fact based
in fact intensive judgment which is why
we commend you all
for your scrupulous attention to
everything that took place
i think that's being sarcastic we
believe that we have shown you
overwhelming evidence in this case
that would convince anyone using their
common sense
that this was indeed incitement
meaning that donald trump's conduct
encouraged violence
the violence was foreseeable and he
acted willfully
in the actions that encouraged violence
mr new goose will take you through that
evidence again
not the whole thing we're almost done
we're almost done
but we don't want it to be said they
never proved this or they never proved
that
because my magnificent team of managers
has stayed up night after night after
night through weeks
to compile all of the factual evidence
and we have put it
before you and we have put it before all
of you
in this public trial because
we love our country
that much
mr nagoos will show you that we've
proven our case
and that president trump committed this
impeachable offense
that we impeached him for on january
13th
and that you should convict him
and when he's finished i will return and
explain
why it's dangerous for us to ignore this
wow
and why you must convict and then we
will rest
mr nuges
real quick thanks to nico young kim
muth nick giado
colin mayer mr president uh thank you
senators good afternoon again
uh as my colleague lead manager raskin
mentioned i know it's been
a long few days and i want to say thank
you that we're very grateful
for your patience for your attention
and the attention that you have paid to
every one of our
managers as they have presented our case
as lead manager raskin mentioned
i hope i trust that we could all agree
that if a president
incites a violent insurrection against
our government that that's impeachable
conduct
so what i'd like to do as we close our
case
is just walk you through why our
evidence
overwhelmingly establishes that
president trump
committed that offense now as you
consider
that question that question of whether
the president
incited an insurrection there are three
questions that
reasonably come to mind was violence
foreseeable did he encourage
violence yes and did he act willfully
yes and i'm going to show you why the
answer to every one of those questions
has to be yes first let's start
with foreseeability was
it foreseeable that the violence would
erupt on january 6th
if president trump lit a spark
was it predictable that the crowd
at the save america rally was poised to
save
for violence that they would fight
literally if provoked to do so
of course it was when president trump
stood up to that podium on january 6
he knew that many in that crowd were
inflamed
or armed were ready for violence
it was an explosive situation and he
knew it
we've shown you the evidence on this
point you've seen it
the images the videos the articles and
the pattern
which show that the violence on that
terrible day
was entirely foreseeable
we've showed you how this all began with
the big lie the claim that the election
was rigged
and that president trump and his
supporters were the victims of a massive
fraud a massive conspiracy
to rip away their votes we've showed you
how president trump spread that lie and
how over the course of months
with his support and encouragement it
inflamed
part of his base resulting
in death threats real world violence
and increasingly extreme calls
to stop this deal
we established that after he lost
the election the president was willing
to do
just about anything to prevent the
peaceful transfer
of power that he tried everything he
could do
to stop it you'll recall the evidence
on the screen him
pressuring and threatening state
election officials
attacking them to the point of literally
calling them
enemies of the state threatening at
least one of them
with criminal penalties then attacking
senators
members of congress all across the media
pressuring the justice department
prompting outcries from
assistant u.s attorneys not to mention
his own attorney general
reportedly telling him that the stolen
election claims were
quote bs not my phrase his
and then as january sixth approached
he moved on to attacking his own vice
president openly
and savagely we recounted
throughout that entire period all the
ways in which president trump
inflamed his supporters with lies that
the election
was stolen and as every single one of us
knows nothing in this country is more
sacred
nothing than our right to vote
our voice and here you have
the president of the united states
telling his supporters
that their voice that their rights as
americans
were being stolen from them ripped away
that made them angry angry enough
to stop the steel to fight like hell
to stop the steal
and we showed you this you saw
the endless tweets the rallies
the statements encouraging and spreading
that big lie
you saw that he did this over and over
again with the same
message each time you must fight
to win it back you must never surrender
no matter what
and remember each time that his
supporters
along the way showed violence
he endorsed it he said it's great
encouraged it
praised it all part of that same demand
to stop the steel
and fight like hell remember the video
that manager plaskett showed you from
texas
some of his supporters encircling a bus
of campaign workers on a highway
people easily could have been killed
easily
what did he do he tweeted it
and made a joke about it at a rally
called them patriots he said it's the
name
as an example of what it means to stop
this deal
when he told his supporters to stop the
steal
they took up arms to literally
intimidate officials
to overturn the election results you saw
the evidence
and so did he and he welcomed it
and when president trump attacked
george's
secretary of state for certifying the
results
his supporters sent death threats
you saw those in great detail from
manager dean
nagoos is excellent what did he do
he attacked the election officials
further
when his supporters gathered together to
have a second
million maga rally that's the rally that
manager plaskett showed you
a rally about the stolen election he
tweeted
that the fight had just begun
what happened next it's not rocket
science
fights broke out stabbings
serious violence
now president trump like all of us he
saw
what happened at that rally he saw all
the violence
the burnings the chaos
how did he respond he tweeted
praise of the event
and then see it on the screen he bought
50 million dollars
50 million dollars worth of ads
to further promote his message
to those exact same people
he immediately joined forces with that
very
same group
he joined forces with the same people
that had just erupted
into violence
was violence predictable
was it obvious that the crowd on january
6
was poised for violence i know a lot of
people in the chat reacting like
they have to explain this to republicans
like their little kids
where you're also fighting you know that
they want to go to recess
and they can't find their binky and they
want
you know a capri sun in the days leading
up to january 6
there were dozens hundreds of warnings
and he knew it he knew the rally would
explode
if provoked he knew all it would take
is a slight push remember
you heard from manager plaskett the
chatter
on social media websites that the trump
administration monitored
and were known to the trump operation it
showed that the people
he invited to the january 6th rally took
this as a serious
call to arms that this was not just any
attack
it was to storm the capital if necessary
to stop the steel and it wasn't just
clear on these
websites that the trump administration
was monitoring
the fbi issued reports about this as a
credible threat
a threat to target us
law enforcement made six arrests that
night before
six arrests newspapers across the city
warned of the risk of the violence
there can be no doubt
that the risk of violence was
foreseeable
and what did he do in the days leading
up to the rally
did he calm the situation ask yourself i
mean
did he call for peace no
he didn't do that he spread his big lie
more
the most dangerous lie as i mentioned
that americans votes were being stolen
and that the final act of theft would
occur
here in the capitol
and then he assembled all of those
supporters he invited them
to an organized event on a specific day
at a specific time matched perfectly
to coincide with the joint session of
congress
to coincide with the steel
that he had told them to stop and then
said let's go to the capitol
by any and all means
again he was told by law enforcement
and all over the news that these people
were
armed and ready for real
violence he knew it i mean he knew it
perfectly well
that he had created this powder keg at
his rally he knew
just how combustible that situation was
he knew
there were people before him who had
prepared
who were armed and armored he knew they
would jump to violence
at any signal at any sign
from him that he needed them to fight
that he needed them to stop the steel
and we all know what happened next
big lie very small hands
did he encouraged the violence
standing in that powder keg
did he light a match
everyone knows the answer to that
question right
the hours of video you all have watched
leave no doubt just remember
what he said on january 6th
all of us here today do not want to see
our election victory stolen
there's never been anything like this
it's a pure theft in american history
everybody knows it
make no mistake this election was stolen
from you
from me and from the country
at the opening we will never give up we
will never concede it doesn't happen
you don't concede when there's theft
involved
i love when he says here's a favorite
term that
all of you people really came up with we
will
stop the steal we must stop this deal
right we will not
let them silence your voices we're not
going to let it happen
not going to let it happen
fight for trump
and you have to get your people to fight
because you'll never take back our
country with weakness
you have to show strength and you have
to be strong
and we fight we fight like hell and if
you don't fight like hell
you're not going to have a country
anymore
there it is you may remember it the
outset
of this trial and i told you you'd hear
three phrases
over and over and over again the big lie
that the election had been stolen
stop the steel and never concede
and fight like hell to stop that steel
you heard those phrases throughout the
course of this trial
video after video statement after
statement
telling his supporters that they should
be patriots
to fight hard to stop the steel
and on that day that day
where did he direct the crowd's ire
he directed them here
to congress he quite
literally at one part of that speech
pointed
at us he told them
to fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell you're not gonna have a
country anymore
and here's the thing that wasn't
metaphorical
it wasn't rhetorical but it's a matter
of already made it
perfectly clear that when he said fight
he meant it
and that when followers in fact fought
when they engaged in violence also walk
down pennsylvania avenue was just
an analogy towards uh
i'm an idiot i don't know it's okay to
break the law because the election
was being stolen you heard it
you remember the clip that manager dean
showed you earlier in this trial he told
them
quote is on the screen when you catch
somebody in a fraud
you're allowed to go by very different
rules
remember how all of his
supporters some of his supporters across
social media
were treating this as a war talking
about bringing in the cavalry yeah walk
down pennsylvania avenue was a metaphor
for
voting the next time we have a chance
that's all he meant
he'd been making it clear for months
so
let's have trial by combat
rudy and rudy you did a great job
he's got guts you know what he's got
guts unlike a lot of people in the
republican party
he's got guts he fights
his message was crystal clear
and it was understood immediately
instantly by his followers
right and we don't have to guess
we don't have to guess as to how
they reacted we can look at how people
reacted to what he said you saw them
and you saw the violence
it's pretty simple he
said it and they did it and they did it
there it is
and we know this because
they told us they told us
in real time during the attack you saw
the affidavits the interviews on social
media
on live tv they were doing this for him
because he asked them to they were
standing by and it wasn't just
insurrectionists who confirmed this
many many people including current and
former officials immediately
recognized that the president had
incited the crowd
that he alone was capable of stopping
the violence that
he did this and he had to call it off
because he was the only one who could
let's see what representative mccarthy
representative gallagher
chris christie oh these are senator
kenzinger
and representative cacco had to say
i could not be fatter or more
disappointed
with the way our country looks at this
very moment people are getting
hurt anyone involved in this you're
hearing me
hearing very loud and clear this is not
the american way
mr president you have got to stop this
you are the only person who can call
this off call it off
pretty simple the president
caused this protest to occur he's the
only one who can make it stop
what the president has said is not good
enough the president has to come
out and and tell his supporters
to leave the capitol grounds right and
to allow the congress
to do their business peacefully
and anything short of that now as many
are pointing out
a lot of people would be hurt by the
policies of a lot of these republicans
that are calling trump out but listen
beggars can't be choosers statements in
one of the saddest days in american
history
the president's role in this
insurrection is undeniable both on
social media ahead of january 6
and in his speech that day he
deliberately promoted baseless theories
creating a
combustible environment of
misinformation and division
to allow the president united states to
incite this attack without consequences
is a direct threat to the future of this
democracy
did the president encourage violence
yes no doubt that he did
final question did the president
act willfully in his actions
that encouraged violence that seems the
easiest to prove
well let's look at the facts he stood
before
an armed angry crowd
known to be ready for violence at his
provocation
and what did he do he provoked them
he aimed them here told them to fight
like hell and that's exactly what they
did
and his conduct throughout the rest of
that terrible day
really only confirms that he acted
willfully
that he incited the crowd and then
engaged in a dereliction of duty
while he continued inflaming the
violence
and again we don't have to guess what he
thought because he told us
remember the video he released at 4 17
p.m
lead manager raskin showed that to you
yesterday the one where he said
quote we had an election that was stolen
from us
remember the tweet that he put out
just a couple hours later 601 p.m on
january 6th
i think it's going to happen many times
you can see it on the slide
that these are the things that happen
when a sacred landslide
election victory is so unceremoniously
and viciously
stripped away
that is what he was focused on
spreading the big lie and praising
the mob that attacked us and our
government
you heard manager sicilini described
reports
the president was delighted enthusiastic
confused that others didn't share his
excitement
as he watched the attack unfold on tv
he cared more about pressing his efforts
to overturn the election than he did
about saving
lives our lives
look at what president trump did that
day
after the rally it's important
he did virtually nothing
we've seen manager
castro mention this that when president
trump wants to stop something
he does so simply easily
quickly but aside from
four tweets and a short clip
during the over five hour long attack
he did nothing
on january six he didn't condemn the
attack
didn't condemn the attackers
didn't say that he would send help to
defend us
or defend law enforcement
he didn't react to the violence with
shock
or horror or dismay as we did
he didn't immediately rush to twitter
and demand in the clearest possible
terms that the mob
dispersed that they stop it that they
retreat
instead he issued messages in the
afternoon that sided
with them the insurrectionists
who had left police officers battered
and bloodied
he reacted exactly the way someone would
react
if they were delighted and exactly
unlike how a person would react
if they were angry at how their
followers
were acting again
ask yourself how many lives would have
been saved how much pain
and trauma would have been avoided if he
had reacted that of the united states is
supposed to act
certainly some
there are two parts of president trump's
failure here
his dereliction of duty that i just have
to emphasize
for a moment first
is what he did to vice president mike
pence
the vice president of the united states
of america turning on your own
vice president edgy was in this building
with an armed mob shouting hang him
the same armed mob
that set up gallows outside you saw
those pictures
and what did president trump do
he attacked him more he singled him out
by name
it's honestly hard to fathom
second our law enforcement
the brave officers who are sacrificing
their lives
to defend us who could not evacuate or
seek cover
because they were protecting us i'm not
going to go through again
what my fellow managers showed you
yesterday
but let me just say this those officers
serve us faithfully and dutifully and
they follow their oaths
they deserve a president who upholds his
who would not risk their lives and
safety
to retain power a president who would
preserve
protect and defend them
but that's not what he did
when they the police still barricaded
and being attacked with poles
he said in his video to the people
attacking them we love you
you're very special very special
children
what more could we possibly
need to know about president trump's
state of mind
senators the evidence is clear
we showed you statements videos
affidavits
that prove president trump
incited an insurrection an insurrection
that he alone had the power to stop
and the fact that he didn't stop it
the fact that he incited a lawless
attack
and abdicated his duty to defend us from
it
the fact that he actually further
inflamed the mob
further inflamed that mob attacking
his vice president while assassins were
pursuing
him in this capital more than requires
conviction
and disqualification we humbly
humbly ask you to convict
president trump for the crime for which
he is
overwhelmingly guilty of
because if you don't
if we pretend this didn't happen
or worse if we let it go
unanswered you're almost condoning it
who's to say it won't happen again
there's congressman jonah goose we will
now hear from jamie raskin once more
then the prosecution expected to rest mr
president
members of the senate first of all thank
you for your close attention and
seriousness of purpose that you've
demonstrated
over the last few days thank you also
for your courtesy
to the house managers as we've come over
here and your strangers in a strange
land
to make our case before this
distinguished an august body
we are about to close and i am proud
that our
managers have been so disciplined and so
focused i think we are closing
somewhere between five and six hours
under the time
that you have allotted to us wow but we
think we've been able
to tell you everything we need to say we
will obviously have the opportunity to
address
your questions and then to do uh to do
a final closing when we get there i just
wanted to leave you with a few thoughts
and again i'm not going to re-traumatize
you by going through the evidence
once again i just wanted to leave you
with a few
thoughts to consider as you enter upon
this very high biblical duty
that you have to render impartial
justice
in this case as you have all sworn to do
and i wanted to start simply by saying
that
in the history of humanity democracy is
an extremely rare
and fragile and precarious and
transitory thing abraham lincoln
knew that when he spoke from the
battlefield
and vowed the government of the people
by the people and for the people shall
not
perish from the earth but he was
speaking
not long after the republic was created
and he was trying to prove that point
that we would not allow it
to perish from the earth for most of
history
the norm has been dictators autocrats
bullies despots tyrants
cowards who take over our governments
for most of the history of the world and
that's why
america is such a miracle
we were founded on the extraordinary
principles of the
inalienable rights of the people and the
consent of the governed
and the fundamental equality of all of
us
you know when lincoln said government of
the people by the
people and for the people and he
hearkened back to the declaration of
independence when he said four score
seven years ago he knew that that wasn't
how we started we started imperfectly we
started as a slave republic lincoln knew
that
but he was struggling to make the
country better
and however flawed the founders were as
men
in their times they inscribed in the
declaration of independence and the
constitution
all the beautiful principles that we
needed to open america up
to successive waves of political
struggle
and constitutional change and
transformation in the country
so we really would become something much
more like lincoln's beautiful
vision of government of the people by
the people
and for the people the world's greatest
multi-racial multi-religious
multi-ethnic
constitutional democracy the envy of the
world
as tom payne said an asylum for humanity
where people would come think about the
preamble
those first three words pregnant with
such meaning we the people
and then all of the purposes of our
government
put into that one action-packed
sentence we the people in order to form
a more perfect union
establish justice ensure domestic
tranquility
provide for the common defense promote
the general welfare
and preserve to ourselves in our
posterity
the blessings of liberty
and then right after that first sentence
the mission statement
for american the constitution what
happens
article 1 the congress is created
all legislative powers herein are
reserved to the congress
of the united states you see what just
happened the sovereign power of the
people
to launch the country and create the
constitution flowed right into congress
and then
you get in article 1 section 8
comprehensive vast powers that all of
you know so well
the power to regulate commerce
domestically internationally
the power to declare war the power to
raise budgets and taxes and to spend
money the power to govern the seat of
government
and on and on and on and then even in
article 1 section 8 clause 18
and all other powers necessary and
property the execution of the foregoing
powers
that's all of us and then you get to
article two
the president four short paragraphs
and the fourth paragraph is all about
what impeachment
how you get rid of a president who
commits high crimes and misdemeanors but
what's the core job of the president
to take care that the laws are
faithfully executed
in our frameworks we're so fearful of
presidents becoming tyrants
and wanting to become kings and despots
that they put the oath of
office right into the constitution they
inscribed it
into the constitution to preserve
protect and defend the constitution
of the united states
we've got the power to impeach the
president the president doesn't have the
power
to the power to impeach us think about
that
the popular branch of government has the
power to impeach the president
the president does not have the power to
impeach us
and as i said before all of us who
aspire and attain the public office are
nothing but the servants of the people
and the way the framers would have it is
the moment that we no longer acted as
servants of the people
but as masters of the people as
violators of the people's rights that
was the time
to impeach
remove convict disqualify start all over
again
because the interests of the people are
so much greater than the interests of
one person
any one person even the greatest person
in the country
the interests of the people or what
count
now when we sit down
and we close
our distinguished counterparts the
defense council who have waited very
patiently
and thank you we'll stand up and seek to
defend the president's conduct
maybe on the facts they might just talk
about i think they will
recipes that he's already been decided
by the senate on tuesday that the senate
has constitutional jurisdiction over
this impeachment case brought to you by
the united states house of
representatives
so we've put that jurisdictional
constitutional issue to bed
it is over it's already been voted on
this is a trial on the facts of what
happened
an incitement as we said is a fact
intensive investigation and judgment
that each of you will have to make
we've made our very best effort to set
forth every single relevant fact that we
know
in the most objective and honest light
we trust we hope that the defense will
understand
the constitutional gravity and solemnity
of this trial by focusing like a laser
beam on the facts
and not return to the constitutional
argument that's
already been decided by the senate
just as a defense lawyer who loses a
motion to dismiss
on a constitutional basis in a criminal
case must let that go
and then focus on the facts which are
being presented by the prosecutors in
detail
they must let this constitutional
jurisdictional argument go
not just because it's frivolous and
wrong as nearly
every expert scholar in america opined
but because it's not
relevant to the jury's consideration of
the facts of the case they don't care
so our friends must work to answer
all of the overwhelming detailed
specific factual and documentary
evidence we have introduced
of the president's clear and
overwhelming guilt in inciting
and inciting violent insurrection
against the union donald trump last week
turned down our invitation to come
testify about his actions
and therefore we've not been able to ask
him any questions directly as of this
point
therefore during the course of their
16-hour allotted presentation we would
pose these preliminary questions to his
lawyers
which i think are on everyone's minds
right now and we in which we would have
asked mr trump
himself if he had chosen to come and
testify about his actions
and inactions when we invited him last
week
one why did president trump not tell his
supporters
to stop the attack on the capitol as
soon as he learned of it
because he liked it thanks for the raid
why did president trump
do nothing to stop the attack for at
least two
hours after the attack began
as our constitutional commander-in-chief
why did he do nothing to send help to
our overwhelmed and besieged law
enforcement officers
for at least two hours on january 16th
after the attack began
because he liked it on january 6 why did
president trump not at any point that
day
condemn the violent insurrection and the
insurrectionists
because you like them and i'll add a
legal question that i hope
his distinguished counsel will address
if a president did invite
a violent insurrection against our
government as of course we allege and
think we've proven in this case
but just in general if a president
incited a violent insurrection
against our government would that be a
high crime and misdemeanor
can we all agree at least on that
senators um i've talked a lot about
common sense in this trial because you
think
i believe that's all you need to arrive
at
the right answer well then we're screwed
you know when tom payne wrote common
sense
the pamphlet that launched the american
revolution
he said that common sense really meant
two different things one common sense
is the understanding that we all have
without
advanced learning and education common
sense
is the sense accessible to everybody but
common sense is also
the sense that we all have in common
as a community
senators america we need to exercise our
common sense
about what happened let's not get caught
up
in a lot of outlandish
lawyers theories here exercise your
common sense
about what just took place in our
country
tom payne wasn't an american as you know
but he came over to help us
in our great revolutionary struggle
against the kings and queens and the
tyrants
and in 1776 in the crisis
he wrote these beautiful words it was a
very tough time for the country
people didn't know which way things were
going to go were we going to win
against all hope because for most of the
rest of human history
it had been the kings and the queens and
the tyrants and the nobles
lording it over the common people could
political self-government work
in america was the question and payne
wrote this pamphlet
called the crisis and in it he said
these beautiful words and with your
permission i'm going to
update the language a little bit
pursuant to a suggestion of speaker
pelosi
uh so as not to offend modern
sensibilities
okay but he said these are the times
that try men and women's souls
these are the times that try men and
women souls the summer soldier
and the sunshine patriot will shrink at
this moment from the service of their
cause in their country
but everyone who stands with us now will
win the love
and the favor and the affection of every
man and every woman for
all time tyranny like hell is not easily
conquered but we have this saving
consolation
the more difficult the struggle the more
glorious in the end
will be our victory good luck in your
deliberations
okay now that's a joke um that is the
presentation for today
thank you now i have two um we're going
to do the adjournment
resolution in a moment i have two other
things that we have to do they're quick
first mr president i ask unanimous
consent that it be in order
uh to make several unanimous consent
requests as if in legislative session
the objections ordered i ask unanimous
consent that on friday february 12
from 10 30 to 11 30 a.m that
notwithstanding adjournment the senate
be able to receive house messages
and executive matters committees be
authorized to report legislative and
executive matters and senators be
allowed to submit statements for the
record
introduce bills and resolutions and make
co-sponsor requests and where applicable
the secretary of the senate on behalf of
the presiding officer
be permitted to refer such matters
the objections
and a second request poignantly
appropriate
at this moment i ask unanimous consent
that pursuant to the order of the senate
of january 24 1901
the traditional reading of washington's
farewell address
take place on monday february 22nd
following the pr prayer and pledge
further that senator portman
be recognized to deliver the address wow
is there objection to that hearing
objection
is ordered and finally mr president i
ask unanimous consent the trial adjourn
until
12 noon tomorrow friday february 12th
and this also constitute the adjournment
of the senate
hearing objection with our objections
ordered
sentence adjourned all right the senate
is object
adjourned that is the end of the
prosecution's case
and tomorrow the defense will begin
uh noon tomorrow we are waiting for some
of the senators to exit we might see
willard mitt romney or others on their
way out
it has been quite a day i do want to
make sure everybody
who supported gets it thank you thanks
to jessica
higginson who signed up at
joinpackman.com and of course we love
our website subscribers and then a bunch
of thanks over on twitch
back ben and hammer worfer
blake a stone ct snowman
as well as mike wells and so many other
different people
appreciate everybody tomorrow will be
a disaster tomorrow will be a disaster
and we will see everybody back
uh very very soon by unanimous consent i
asked to adjourn the stream and uh
hearing no objections i'm gonna do it
all right we'll see everybody tomorrow